[Music]
look what I become
okay so if you've hit the gym today by
the time this podcast is done your brain
is gonna have a workout because these
two guys are some of the sharpest guys
online when it comes down to talk in
economics both of them have a big
YouTube podcast show uh you'll find
everywhere one of them is George Gammon
I think George I've been on your show
before a couple years ago is a renowned
American real estate investor
entrepreneur YouTuber and teacher
schooling macroeconomics
he uh creates and stars in The Rebel
capitalist show he doesn't believe in
capitalism he believes in free market
capitalism and yeah it's his uh have
here and then the other gentleman that's
here with us is ran I was with Iran and
scaramucci and who was the other
gentleman that was with him actually
remember to scare him
because we had a really good time and
like I said to your great host uh he's a
co-founder and CEO of unchain capital A
blockchain investment fund and advisory
Service uh in 2017 he launched crypto
Trader the world's first televised
cryptocurrency show featured on CNBC
today he is the host and executive
producer the show has had huge success
and is the most viewed show on the
channel today his show is called crypto
yes
thanks for coming on yes thanks for
having us great to have you guys so you
live where you you're based out of South
Africa Cape Town and you're out of
marine so neither one of you live in the
state no I know for sure you would live
in California or Portland OR New York or
some states I actually left South Africa
a couple of years ago came to live in
the states spent two years in New York
spent a couple of months in Miami and
then went back to South Africa that's
that's the story for another time but
and you're not leaving you're staying
put I may come to Florida I I have a I
have an affair with fly I have a live
affair with Florida I love Florida so
how about yourself George you're staying
put you're not moving yeah you know I
went there originally in 2014 Just for
investment opportunities and I saw the
weather perfect food was amazing people
are awesome salsa dancing yeah Adam
knows what I'm talking about yeah yeah
yeah the opportunity to go with George
to a night out in Medellin dinner dinner
and a movie is that the time you guys
wanted at the church and the pastor was
giving great previews
it was a great incredible message for
for guys who are you know the guys that
listen to the podcast we haven't known a
podcast since last Tuesday it's been a
crazy week maybe we'll talk about some
of the stories we had a great
conversation on Thursday with someone
maybe we'll kind of get into it in a
minute here but more importantly today I
have so many stories I want to go
through with you with Tom with Adam with
Rand with all of you economy-wise but if
you don't mind for the audience that
doesn't know you of course I gave the
intro here but maybe take a minute and
give your background of what you've done
in the past where you are today both of
you will start with you first yeah so I
retired in 2012 uh as an entrepreneur a
long time entrepreneur and I didn't know
anything about the fed the yield curve
nothing about macro at all but I knew
that I wanted to invest my own money I
didn't want to delegate that to
financial planner so I started studying
and the first uh stuff that I came
across the first content I came across
is Milton Friedman's free to choose
Series going back to the 1970s and the
1980s and that just like hit me like a
bag of bricks I mean it just really
really resonated so from there I went to
Thomas Seoul I started studying guys
like Jim Rogers and Doug Casey and Rick
Rule and Peter Schiff and I just became
completely obsessed with it it became my
passion and then in 2019 I started the
YouTube channel and that grew for
whatever reason that grew very quickly
it's still kind of amazes me that people
actually want to see me talk in front of
the camera but for some reason they do
and then we started another Channel The
Rebel capitalist Channel when they hold
up the name the Mandate thing came out I
was really pushing back against that and
that channel is really set up and
designed to do that and uh now we turn
that into a podcast that's doing really
well and that's how I got to where I am
today we just had our live conference
this past weekend where we had Schiff
and Mike Maloney and Lynn Alden and uh
Snyder and Brent Johnson a lot of people
Kiyosaki was there yeah and it's just
become this uh this this movement that
I'm very proud of I love it I love the
work you do when your stuff pops up uh
and I'm listening to it I get smart
about it time I'm done listening to what
you have to say your views are very uh
you're a good teacher and the way you
explain things and it's obvious why
you're growing how about yourself thank
you
um typical entrepreneur story I think
uh.com raised money for an internet
startup I was supposed to start an
online wealth management Community blew
myself up in the.com bubble went in
Sullivan for the first time
uh built myself up built and sold the
biggest marketing and advertising agency
in Africa very big acquisition in Africa
over 150 million dollars and um then
went into cryptocurrency full time and
when I went into cryptocurrency there
was no information I just I was looking
for information in 2016 and 2017 and
there was Zero information
somehow convinced CNBC to let me run the
world's first televised cryptocurrency
investment shot and we went live we ran
the show for a couple of years
and then I realized that media and the
way that CNBC were doing it is
not the future of media so I broke away
and started my own 24 7 365 crypto media
platform you were talking 24 7. that's a
lot I talked 24.
no sleeping
yeah so uh today we run crypto banter
which is a crypto media channel
um an amazing Community
um we're building towards 24 7 365
credible crypto streaming content uh we
do about five hours a day now and yeah
very strong Community one of the most
loyal communities in crypto
um having the time of our lives I love
it listen if you if you're if you're
able to create content have fun and
you're you have a different point of
view you will find the audience
eventually you know this game is a very
honest game if you don't do it right
they will tell you if you do it right
they'll show up I agree and it's a
ruthless game because if you don't do it
right you can get you can get canceled
in a minute but I think more importantly
for me the first time that I built a
business and I needed to exit I was
working with a goal in mind and I had
something to prove and this time I'm
actually just there because I'm having a
lot of fun and it's like
I can't imagine having more fun I just
can't imagine yeah it's a very different
mindset the second time around because
you just do what you love and everything
falls into place and in the first time
around you always got something to prove
so I gotta say it's very impressive that
you have four kids and you're only 27
years old
and I respect before you started early
and it is what it is so how about we get
into some store a lot of them to cover
cover here uh since you guys are all a
lot of economy we got a lot of economy
stories to get into it let's start off
with jobless claims from Fox Business
and then we'll do some musk with the new
CEO we'll talk about Tesla stock we'll
talk about U.S treasuries inflation
Apple's new card Jamie Diamond with the
debt default that people are concerned
about Bud Light parent company stock
downgraded by HSBC we'll talk some
blockchain we'll talk some Federal
Reserve with the FED now uh and some
other stories in the back is what we'll
get into with CNN Chris Licht CNN Town
Hall we haven't responded to the CNN
Town Hall president a bunch of other
things let's start off with uh jobless
claim rise sharply to highest level
since
2021 again this is a fox business story
uh let's see this here the number of
Americans filing for unemployment
benefits last week reached the highest
level since 2021 with initial claim
surging to buy 22 000 to
264. this figure is well above the
pre-pandemic average of 218 claims and
marks the sharpest level of jobless
claim since October 2021 continuing
claims which represent Americans
continuously receiving unemployment
benefits Rose slightly to 1.81 million
indicating a potential cool enough in
the historically tight labor market
economists anticipate further increases
in unemployment as a result of rising
interest rates leading to potential
reductions in consumer and business
spending the FED projections suggest
that officials expect the unemployment
rate to rise above 4.6 percent by the
end of next year up from a current three
and a half percent this could result in
over 1 million job losses by the end of
this year Tom what are your thoughts on
the story well this is exactly what the
FED wanted to cause is with um whether
they're the direct cause of it or it's
now we're going to a cycle because
because we had over hired 20 and 21 but
this is what the FED wants to see is
rising unemployment and jobless claims
is where it starts what's really
interesting is right now the employment
unemployment rate according to
government's 3.4 percent and so that's
5.7 almost five and three quarter
million people unemployed officially but
then we have this 1.9 million jobless
claims in there so when you look at this
and say that the last week the week's
claims is 264 000. that's like 25
percent of the current jobless claims so
it looks like this is inflating LinkedIn
came out yet another tech company just
laid off a little under a thousand
people and the list of tech layoffs we
had a couple sheets in here it was just
incredible Morgan Stanley 3000 3M 6000
to name a couple companies that were
outside Tech the headlines have been
Tech layoffs but it's all it's all
coming and people have been asking what
does this mean does this mean the
recession is here remember that's what
they're asking does this mean that it
keeps interest rates flat in June when
he gets along and we found an
interesting chart here really quick
Malik do you have the blue bars League
just to give you a context to what Tom's
talking about when you said this is what
the FED wanted I believe you're
referencing The Showdown almost between
uh Jerome Powell and Senator Kennedy of
Louisiana when they had a little thing
going on his character was talking about
that's his exactly talking about you're
saying yeah joblessness to go up you
want people to be upset and out of work
yeah once you can kind of get past the
almost like uh
he's talking about something called the
Phillips curve so back in the Phillips
curve they had this idea where there was
an inverse relationship between the
inflation rate and the unemployment rate
so if the unemployment was low uh then
inflation would be high and if the
unemployment as the unemployment rate
got higher then inflation should come
back down that was totally debunked in
the 1970s but for some reason that's
still part of their playbook now one
thing I'd also point out about jobs if
you go back a couple weeks or last uh
Friday I think it was the non-farm
payroll came out this blowout number
right but then they also revised the
prior two months down by like 150 000
jobs and I also saw a chart on Twitter
that was very interesting this chart was
how many consecutive months that the
actual number exceeded expectations and
it went back let's say 20 years right
and the most uh it got up to was about
four or five months consecutively where
the actual number exceeded expectations
now we're on 13. 13. I mean it literally
goes off the charts but what they do is
they've been revising down every single
month prior you see so you when you
think about it it seems like what
they're doing is they're coming out with
a blowout number just to make the
administration look good and then the
next month they're just revising it
because they know that no one will pay
attention to that and they'll just sweep
it under the rug so if you look at the
revisions as the actual number then they
jive a lot more with this story that
you're reporting on than the actual
headline non-farm payroll so it's very
suspicious to say the least I love that
you use the word suspicious because I
completely agree with you and I also saw
the um uh you sounds like you're reading
it the same way I was about two months
ago they had gone in and revised the
definition of seeking work and it was
actually 5.1 million were were had quote
given up and so they pulled them out of
the
166 million total Workforce that they
estimate right yeah 62 participation
rate about 166 million people in the
workforce and they what they did they
pulled it out but if you put the two
together and you doubled it the
unemployment rate instead of being at
that point four would have still been
closer to seven and three quarters yeah
yeah and and the birth death model
correct I don't know if you saw that but
I don't know if you guys want me to
explain that but there's something
there's a an adjustment for the headline
non-farm payroll it's just birth death
so what they try to do it's not human
beings it's businesses so what they try
to do is Guess How many businesses were
started and how many businesses failed
within that time frame and then since
that's I don't know why they can't
report but for some reason those brand
new businesses can't reports they have
to guess as to how many jobs were
actually created based on how many llc's
came into existence and what's odd is
they just assume that every single LLC
that's created has x amount of employees
and you know as an entrepreneur that's
how they're guesstimating yeah that's
one of the reason that's one of the ways
they do that and so I I saw a lot of
people that I follow on Twitter that I'm
friends with that that are very very
smart yeah and they took out that
adjustment for the birth death model and
then if you do that then it was
basically zero and it was much much
lower which will most likely next month
get revised even lower than that
headline number so it's all this kind of
financial engineering so to speak that's
making the jobs numbers look as as good
as they can and keep in mind that's the
only thing that the fed and the central
planners and the Janet Yellen types have
to say hey look at how great the economy
is because every single other metric
that they have that even the FED said
like a year ago that this is how you
tell if we're in a recession I'm
referring to something called a
near-term forward spread I can I can
explain that if you'd like me to but
they used to say well this is what you
have to look at this is what you have to
look at until that inverted and then
like uh no don't look at that anymore
so this is all they've got left is the
unemployment rate and that's why they
might be kind of using these types of
financial services speaking of
suspicious but we did this on the
podcast two weeks ago how Biden created
10 million new jobs whatever the crazy
number was Rob you probably have the
link but it turned out it was just
people who basically were fired during
covet and then just got their jobs back
these aren't really creative jobs so it
sounds like but you can inflate a lot of
these numbers what do we expect we I
mean it follows the process you first
increase interest rates we've had the
fastest interest rate increases since
since anyone can remember naturally
that's going to bring down inflation
because spending is the first thing that
stops and only after spending stops do
people stop hiring people and so the job
numbers are coming down they are
manipulated
they lag but I think more importantly I
think this is this is probably the more
important thing the fed's Mandate is
based on a a concept which was debunked
so the fed's Mandate is based on
inflation and unemployment that's that's
what the FED looks at if you've been
looking at what Jerome Powell has been
doing and saying no matter what happens
around them no matter what we think
about the banking collapse or whatever
else we're focused on inflation and
we're focused on unemployment and that's
really where the the Focus areas and I
think that the Mandate of the FED for
this kind of scenario is probably wrong
and I mean I like this in the in the FED
but I think the Mandate needs to be
redefined yeah and another thing that's
interesting we're on the topic of
unemployment is uh one of the
presentations from this weekend a good
friend of mine Jeff Snyder who's
probably the smartest guy I've ever met
uh he looks at those curves like the
near-term forward spread which is
basically the current three-month
treasury yield uh minus the few the the
three-year treasury yield that the
market expects in 18 months based on a
variety of factors the price 10. yeah
well the yield so you look at the
current three-month yield compared to
what the market is predicting the
three-month yield will be in 18 months
and then you subtract that and right now
there's like a 200 basis point inversion
so what the market is saying is that
they're predicting an 18 months or
within that time frame the two-year
excuse me the three-month treasury yield
will be 200 basis points lower than it
is today so then he said you got to sit
back and ask yourself what does that
mean what what if if the if the
three-month treasury yield goes down by
that much what would the economic
environment have to look like and where
would the FED have to have interest
rates as a result of that economic
environment some of the conclusions that
he came to is he thought that
unemployment would be at double digits
by the end of this year
double digits double unemployment double
digits and he thought that based on that
and based on the yield curve the normal
yield curve and the near-term forward
spread and the euro dollar Futures curve
and whatnot that the FED would most
likely be at zero percent by the end of
this year what you're saying is pretty
shocking you're saying it's a three and
a half percent now by the end of the
year no no the FED funds is right now I
think you're talking about unemployment
right well yeah I am I'm sorry I got
unemployment as well so unemployment
goes from 3.5 percent to double digits
yeah by the end of this year and the
recession that's producing that causes
the FED to take rates fed funds down
from let's say five percent all the way
back down to zero percent and that that
and then think about what type of
economy think about the banking crisis
the thing about the Black Swan event
that we would have to have in order for
the FED to drop rates that quickly and
another thing that I would add there's a
big psychological component here right
because you guys if you study history
you guys know that history remembers
Paul volcker very well it does not
remember Arthur Burnswell
right and he was the Fed chair that
preceded Paul volcker everyone thinks
that he didn't have the balls basically
to take interest rates high enough to
break the back of inflation and sure
enough Paul volcker comes in and he had
the huevos to get in there and do what
needed to be done even though it was
very unpopular so if you're Jerome
Powell who do you want to be remembered
as obviously Paul volcker so from a
psychological standpoint that puts him
in a place where if he's going to air on
one side or the other he's going to err
on the side of taking rates too high but
you see the market knows that and even
when you include that psychological
component they still are betting that
he's going to take rates almost down to
zero or around that uh area by the end
of this Union Snyder no the market the
market because if you look at how the
market is placing their bets the the the
bond market as an example that's what
they're saying is going to come to
fruition in the bond market is the Smart
money I mean if you look at just the
basic you curve with a two-year treasury
in the 10-year treasury you can take
that all the way back to 1950s and that
has almost a hundred percent accuracy
when that inverts you 99 of the time you
get a recession now what's interesting
is right now it's still inverted so the
two-year treasury yield is higher than
the 10-year treasury but the stuff
doesn't hit the fan when the curve is
inverted it hits the fan when the curve
is no longer inverted and what usually
happens is you have a bad invert or when
the yield curve steepens you have a bad
steepener and a good steepener the bad
steepener is when the two-year goes back
down below the tenure and almost always
that's a result of the FED dropping
rates as a result of some sort of crisis
situation so those people that think
that the FED drops rates the stock
market's going to rip higher that
unfortunately they're on the wrong side
of history and they might get a a rude
awakening to say the least the bond
market is Right more often than the FED
narrative is right and if you're looking
at what the yield curve is almost always
right and if you look at what the FED
narrative is now the FED narrative is
now we're going to continue raising
until the data until the data says
otherwise but I think Paul Tudor Jones
was on CNBC today and he said I wish
they would say something what like what
they really wanted to say so I'm not a
big I'm not a big believer in the Black
Swan event which you which you spoke
about but I do think that there is
something else that threatens the job
market and could cause mass unemployment
and I think it's going to happen in the
next three to six months but I do think
it's gonna happen the next 12 to 18
months and that's AI so I think no one
is is forecasting for the dramatic
change that AI is going to have on
people's jobs because right now it's
just chatbots and we're seeing the
beginning of it but remember that AI
technologically does that yeah and I
think that that's gonna cause a lot of
people to lose their jobs and I don't
think we've recreated the jobs the new
jobs as quickly as we're going to lose
the old jobs and I think that's a big
thing that we're going to look out for
as I say I don't think it's three to six
months from here but I do think that 12
to 18 months from here we've we've got a
massive jobs problem yeah and we're
gonna have a lot of unemployed people
yeah but you you layer that on top of
the 21 trillion dollar Time Bomb which
is commercial real estate
I mean let's not forget about that we
see Silicon Valley Bank going Bust or
signature all these regionals well who
do you think finances all these
commercial real estate deals and and
keep in mind when you I mean you know
this when you do a commercial real
estate deal to buy a 40 story building
or something like that you're not
getting a 30-year fixed rate mortgage
you're taking that out with maybe
two-year debt maybe five-year debt and
within the next uh I think it's within
the next two years you guys might know I
think it was like 2 to 2.5 trillion
dollars worth of commercial real estate
that needs to be rolled over debt right
so if you think about where you got that
debt to begin with was these regionals
and they're all going bust so when you
go back to that Regional Bank you think
that they're going to be chomping at the
bit to give you a loan absolutely not
and that just blew a hole in their
balance sheet so if you can even get a
loan there's going to be a massive risk
premium on there in other words the
interest rate is going to be extremely
high as your cash flow has gone down
because your occupancy rates have gone
down the cap rates have gone down
because the treasuries have gone up in
yield and that's going to you know cap
rates are going to follow treasuries
because that's a competing asset class
so basically you have your expenses
going way way up if you can even get
debt to roll over and your income is
going way way down your Equity is going
down because cap rates are going up and
this creates a whole big problem I mean
personally I don't think that we're over
the banking crisis I think we're
probably in inning two or three inning
two or three yeah and you look at Europe
and the commercial real estate is just
as bad over there yeah so I mean they
started with Credit Suisse but I
wouldn't be there's nowhere to go three
years ago for commercial real estate I
agree that we're in in two or three yeah
and it's good it's it's gonna be pretty
bad because you look back at two years
ago and what paper did I have at Libor
plus X now look where Libor is it's
impossible to refi I can't refi it and
my asset value just is pick a city is
taking anywhere for what 17 to 33
percent down in the US market on cities
we saw that building in San Francisco
had a uh it's got a 330 million dollar
asset value and a bunch of paper that's
underneath that building and they were
expecting it to go sub 100 in a 60
million yeah they're just gonna give the
keys back to the bank I was reading a
statistic the other day that if you
combined all all the occupancy in New
York City you'd have 34 empire state
buildings
and think about that what a statistic
yeah but it does mean that we're getting
to the end of the tightening cycle and
it does mean that we're going to get
into an easing cycle much quicker than
yeah but let's not forget the interest
rate fallacy that Milton Friedman points
out that when interest rates are low
that means usually that means money is
tight
well for a lot of small businesses that
means the interest rate's Infinity
yeah I I mean I I yeah I hear you I hear
you but I hear you but we're getting to
the end of the cycle we're seeing real
estate we're seeing jobless claims start
going up we're seeing real estate
starting to starting to come down and
that's usually the end of the cycle in
the beginning of the new cycle so I
think that the tightening cycle
certainly in my opinion is is all the
dining cyclers yeah yeah I think it's I
think it's close to done I agree with
Paul Tudor Jones I know you guys had it
up there but um I agree with Paul Tudor
Jones and I think it's close to done
yeah yeah I would agree Tom will you say
something yeah the period at the end of
the sentence is I wanted to step back
from the numbers and manipulated numbers
I really want to know what the consumer
thought so I dug in and I found I found
this if we can go to it now the uh blue
bars and what it did is it broke up the
generations right now and then it said
okay what do these Generations feel
about job security well if you run a
national poll 53 of people in America
are not World worried at all about job
security then you peel back the onion 82
send a Boomers close to retirement or
fighting the last inning of their own uh
Financial War 82 percent that they're
not worried about job security until you
get to gen Z Millennials only 25 percent
of gen Z and 37 percent of Millennials
and 48 of Gen X are
feeling good about job security so you
forget about the manipulated you know
unemployment figures that we're talking
about and go look at what the common man
this is a broad-based survey and this
tells you it tells me that what the
average worker is feeling is that the
younger Generations you know the ones
that extorted the 20 raises during covid
yeah yeah or suddenly
leaving about job security but this is
all directly connected you know what
this reminds me of a video I did the
other day on these buy now pay later
loans I don't know if you guys saw this
The Firm at fintech companies and others
like them no just how many people right
now how many Americans are using buy now
pay later for they said 44 of Americans
said that they will likely have to use a
buy now pay later loan within the next
six months and then that survey broke
down you know what do you think you'll
need that buy now pay uh later loan for
in 20 so 44 of Americans said that and
of the the 44 21
said that they needed to buy groceries
well I mean here's a story that you're
talking about right Americans are
spending big credit cards uh here's what
that means for the possibility of a
research on CNBC story consumer spending
accounts for more than half of the
economy making it a significant factor
in maintaining economic stability Curt
long Chief Economist at National
Association of federally insured Credit
Union stated if consumer spending is
strong that alone is generally speaking
enough to keep the economy from slipping
into recession
in the first quarter of 2023 GDP showed
a modest growth of 1.1 percent compared
to the previous quarter the improvement
from the mid-2022 GDP figures which
initially raised recession concern can
be attributed to consumer spending
consumers are spending despite Rising
prices leading to a decline in personal
savings many Americans particularly
those with lower incomes are
increasingly reliant on credit cards for
their day-to-day expenses Bank of
America Institute economists reported
that roughly 29 percent of household
earnings
earning less than 50 000 a year are
using credit cards for spending 29 right
Additionally the average tax refund has
decreased negatively impacting spending
for household that rely on on refunds
yeah so when you're in a situation like
this and you're seeing data and then
you're looking at the stock market
Market's doing okay nothing crazy is
going on
and you're like well you know I guess
we're kind of recovering everything's
going back to normal you know well you
know real estate's not really dropping
that much yeah maybe a little bit of
movement yeah it's gone down maybe five
10 15 points in certain markets but no
one's still selling their house because
they know if I sell the house I still
have to go buy a house a similar price
and I'm not going to go out there and
try risking fine so maybe it's not as
bad as it is and then there's the other
side that's saying listen it's not as
bad as it is they're expecting a
recession Q4 q1 of next year it's coming
10 percent unemployment Etc they kind of
like what you were talking about and
there's a third party that says yeah
it's going to be soft Landing it's not
going to be as bad as people think it is
things you have to worry about as AI you
got to worry about the the debt the
default election the real there's so
many different things going on more
important in the economy the economy
stuff about fear porn it's not real
they're just trying to scare you for
eyeballs what do you say to those people
that's two words yield curve
that's it so what I mean by that is I
know I know what you mean by that talk
to a person that doesn't consume
Financial content all day the regular
person sitting at home they're 35 years
old makes 82 Grand a year household
income 130 135 for sure they're like
George what are you talking about
explain to me what I should be worried
about I shouldn't be worried about yeah
so let's go back to 2020. okay let's go
back to March and we all know what
happened in March you know we thought
the world was going right so around that
time the FED funds was right around one
percent now they were supposed to meet
on a Wednesday and that an emergency
meeting on the Sunday prior and they met
that night and they came out and
announced that they were going to drop
rates right down to zero so from one
percent down they're going to drop it by
100 basis points and they were going to
commit to basically QE infinity and
they're going to commit to doing up to a
trillion dollars a day in the repo
market so just providing that type of
liquidity kind of the the oil the the
lubricant of the financial system well
the very next day the stock market went
down by about 1500 points and it
continued to go down until we got the
cares act where you had this fiscal
stimulus and then the market started to
go back up but my point is that the FED
dropped rates by a hundred basis points
boom right why because we thought the
world was coming to an end so what these
curves are telling us right now and
they're almost always right is that the
FED is going to do that again
by the end of 2023 but this time they're
not going to drop from one percent to
zero percent this time they're going to
drop from five percent maybe not all at
one time but they're going to drop from
five percent down to zero percent or
close to that right so think about that
if they had to drop by a hundred percent
because of covet because the world is
coming in what does the world look like
if they're dropping by 400 basis points
or 500 basis points
what does it look like what does it look
like it looks like worse than what we
saw in 2020 it looks like worse than the
GFC unpack that
it looks okay so it looks like
unemployment just going up past double
digits I wouldn't be surprised I don't
know about 2023 but going into 2024 I
would not be surprised if unemployment
got north of 15 15 absolutely absolutely
and I think that you're looking at a
over the long period of time because the
residential real estate doesn't crash uh
it slowly goes down over time I mean it
peaked out in 2006 and we didn't see a
bottom until 2012. when you adjust for
inflation and you can see that real
price decline as nominal prices are flat
if we have a certain degree of inflation
but I think that over the long you know
the next five or six years you're going
to see real estate really come down
commercial real estate I think might
crash but then you're looking at the s p
going down by you know 30 40 50 and we
have to real another thing to keep in
mind here is tax receipts Patrick
because you know that the government is
spending like a a drunken sailor will
say right so they have this huge deficit
and if we go into recession what are
they going to do they're going to have
to increase deficit spending because
this is monetary heroin and what I mean
by that is if you do 5 trillion of
deficit spending to cover covid you just
you have to keep doing more and more and
more and more to get the exact same
result so let's say this time they have
to do 10 trillion in deficit spending
right
okay well let's also keep in mind that
tax receipts are not a derivative of tax
rates
that is total nonsense because you go
back to the 1940s regardless of whether
the rate has been 90 or 25 percent they
still get about 18 percent
of of GDP as far as tax revenue right
but now especially since the economy has
been so financialized since the 1980s
and 1990s now tax receipts are really
tied to the stock market and what we
have seen and this we can talk about
this I was talking about this limb last
night is this blow up in the one month
treasury where the other day it went up
in one day by a hundred basis points I
mean you never see that type of
volatility ever and this most likely was
a result of the government coming out
that day and saying hey guess what not
only do we have this debt ceiling crisis
but all that tax money that you thought
we were going to get we're not getting
that because asset prices haven't gone
down this or up this year they've gone
down this year and so if we have this
recession if those the market goes down
by that much tax receipts are going to
go down by that much as well at a time
when the government is having to spend
more than they did during uh covid to
try to patch this hole right and then
then who is buying these treasuries you
know at the short end you might have a
buyer but the long end you know do we go
into a recession where interest rates
are actually going up at the long end I
mean these are all you know questions
that we need to think so by the way the
last time uh did somebody say something
no I was I was going to say I didn't I
didn't share such a gloomy view to be
honest
view I'm coming to you next so last time
we had 15 was 1940 14.6 we got up there
we got close to that covered yeah we I
mean but you can't really count covet
because covert to me is is uh I
understand what you're saying what covet
to me was a complete different uh you
know Black Swan that we went through
non-black Swan 1940. well you're talking
about unemployment unemployment okay
14.6 yes what did I say did I say
something
so the entire hospitality industry was
told to stay home so this this is the
part I really I'm really curious to know
George ran your thoughts on that time
you as well is
here's the difference we're where I uh
become a little bit skeptical of my own
uh uh trends that I look at and I say
this should move this
that should move this this should get
destroyed this should come up
the last three years it's been a little
out of whack that the stuff that moves
another thing doesn't move it anymore so
why is that what is the difference
between 1940 and today here's the
difference that I see and I want you to
push back and and find a leak in my
argument 1940 we were on the gold
standard you couldn't really manipulate
that much you were still protected by
the gold standard as much as you wanted
to manipulate you know and kind of play
the game you couldn't fully you could do
it don't get me wrong Joseph Kennedy
mastered it in 20s and he caused the
whole 1929 all that stuff fine but you
still had a certain level of the FED
still had a certain level of
accountability to what they could do and
what they couldn't do Post you know 1972
73 gold standard were off of a Nixon
whether you agree with it or not you
know to where we are today today these
guys have more levers to control and
manipulate and play with than ever
before they're like yeah you know what
we're going to kind of go like this yeah
what can I go go like this like the
whole thing with the default like you
know could we really default back in the
day days every time we wanted to spend
something and this is this is like a
little over 100 years ago you have to
avoid it you know reported line by line
then all of a sudden it becomes what no
let's just let's just increase the debt
limit and let us do whatever we want to
do with the money because we need it and
you know what now we make it political
now becomes divisives I think they have
so many different things to manipulate
to put temporary Band-Aids on a
catastrophic event that they could delay
that each time you're like yeah they
delayed it for five more years yeah they
delayed it for 10 more years do you
agree or do you disagree with the fact
that they have more manipulation today
than before oh absolutely and I want to
be clear I'm not saying that there's a
high probability that they default if we
even if you know if we go to this debt
ceiling thing I think that's going to be
resolved uh for sure isn't it always
resolved yeah yeah it's almost I'm less
concerned about the default we'll get
into that story I'm more concerned about
15 unemployment q1 of 2024. yeah but so
what you're saying is what Jerome Powell
is saying is that hey I've got the tools
for this yeah right well okay did he
have the tools for Silicon Valley Bank
he came out and created that new
facility I forgot what is called the
bank fund lending facility or something
like that but then what did we have then
we had First Republic you see what
happens every single time they come out
say that I've got a tool for you know
we've got the tools don't worry Adam
we've got the tools
oh well I'm actually ought to create
more tools because they're always behind
the insured though it was to protect the
the positive deposit or not the no they
never said they're going to protect the
investment Banks
out no no the the FED set up a a
facility so that those Banks could
unload those assets off their balance
sheet at 100 cents on the dollar well
they could borrow against it they
couldn't unload them they could borrow
against them 100 yeah but they would
have to repay the loan yeah it's not
overflowing but well if they had a
deposit flight they could get those
assets they could get 100 cents on the
dollar they could borrow 100 cents on
the dollar for the face value of those
assets correct which they thought was
their problem but then you had First
Republic or it didn't solve that problem
so what I'm saying is the Fed thinks
they can solve these problems but but
they're way behind the curve and if they
weren't behind the curve they wouldn't
have to do 45 rounds of quantitative
easing as an example you know that's an
example they're tool it just have to do
over and over and over again well if
it's so powerful why do they have to do
it 45 times and if they've got all the
tools for this why do we still have
these blow-ups when they have to create
another tool
you see the problem here is the the
global monetary system is broken
and if you if it wasn't broken you
wouldn't have a Silicon Valley Bank you
know why couldn't they go to the
discount window why couldn't they go to
the repo Market why couldn't they use
all of these free market solution well
not the discount window but the repo
Market why couldn't they use these free
market Solutions where the other Banks
would give them the liquidity they need
because there's too much counterparty
risk in the system because all the
banksters know that the system's broken
and the only person that's willing to
come in and clean up the mess is JP
Morgan if they unload the risk of the
asset side of the balance sheet they're
incorporating onto the taxpayer and they
say oh by the way in order for us to do
this deal we're going to have to borrow
50 billion dollars from the taxpayer and
I don't know if you read that story but
they took an immediate gain of 2.6
million and they're projected to make
500 million dollars a year on that deal
JP Morgan is and he didn't even have any
out-of-pocket cost to do the deal and he
said FDIC you've got to insure 80
percent of the losses that I incur if I
absorb this balance sheet I mean it's
just like it's it's a freebie but you
see my point but if the IC assisted it's
sdi's FDIC assisted rescue packages
which means the taxpayer is funding
assisting JPMorgan and the bigger banks
in rescuing the smaller Banks that's
what that's all it is oh rescuing not
rescuing I'm sorry yeah taking taking
over but that goes back to my question
though that goes back to my question
that they will use every lever today
because there is no accountability to
manipulate any data point they want
that's what I'm saying yeah so you go
back to covid yeah and everyone said
what you're saying is that there's a fed
put there's a fed put George so we
shouldn't worry about it because they
can kick the can further down the road
that's the argument that's what seems to
be happening that in covid you could see
that the fed put expired because the FED
tried to come in with their put and the
market kept crashing it just said you
know what the FED puts done how long did
it crash though what was it probably a
week
but it kept crashing until the
government came out that's the point
where okay so then we go from a fed put
to a government put so the question now
becomes can the government act the same
way that the FED did and if we are in an
environment where inflation is zero
percent or they're worried about
deflation the answer would most likely
be yes assuming that the Democrats and
the Republicans could get along who
knows right but if we're in an
environment where inflation is extremely
high you know is the public going to
have the stomach for the Biden or any
Administration to come out and say yes
we're going to do another 5 trillion
when they realize that that 5 trillion
created this inflation that they're
having to suffer through now you think
the Public's going to say no to it you
think the Public's going to say no to it
they're going to say yes they're going
to open up their arms they said drop the
drop I mean it's not look this is why
the the the system that we have in
America in a way it's broken because
there's no such thing as earning the
right to vote anybody if you allow the
majority to vote this was a republic
gradual is becoming more of a democracy
where the individual is not protected
from the majority it's a complete
different concept of what America was
truly founded for that's my concern my
concern is
there is way too many levers to
the real economy and put a big ass
Band-Aid so everybody thinks oh things
are great guys let's go ahead and get
re-elected like even before midterms
what happened pre-mid terms uh let's use
our uh all the stuff that we've been
having for oil and all that in our
Reserve guys dump it dump it dude use
all of it use all of it yeah
six dollars five dollars and fifty cents
five dollars 450. did you notice how in
the last midterms it's supposed to be a
red wave boom it's not what happened
well we fixed the economy a month later
back to the same again so the the
point I'm trying to make to you isn't I
disagree with you I think we should be
at 15 I think the mess that we have
should be a 15 out of the system but but
we have created zero George zero
accountability where we allowed these
guys to get away with murder because
whoever controls the knob controls what
they can do to delay the current issue
that's my concern yeah we're aligned on
the same page I'm worried it was
controlled enough I remember before the
elections there was the recession and
then the definition of recession was two
two quarters
but then they had three quarters and
then they said no no but that's not
that's not a recession that's not the
definition of realization it's okay give
us what the definition of a recession is
well that's not the definition of
recession that that was the manipulation
yeah the other big manipulation is
marking not having to Mark T balls to
Market in other words not you know when
the interest rate goes up not having to
reduce the value of your holding on your
balance sheet if you're holding
government treasury rules all right
mortgage background or more good-backed
Securities not what that means is that
it's that is manipulation that is as if
you're if I buy a property today and I
buy the property today for a million
dollars and then the interest rate goes
up and the property is only worth six
hundred thousand dollars if I say that
I'm going to hold the property until the
end of the mortgage then you don't have
to write it down and that's manipulation
because you don't know as a bank when
you're when you're when your depositors
are going to want their money back and
when that happens you're gonna have to
sell these mortgage-backed Securities or
these tables to honor that yeah and so
the biggest manipulation and the biggest
scam was not having to Mark these things
down basically a counting trip really
we're able to put an account called hold
to maturity is is what he's referring to
yeah it is a very good point all they
had to do was say we're gonna hold these
t-balls to maturity and you could write
them at the value of maturity
even though the value had decreased by
40 so a million dollar table if you held
a million dollar table for 10 years
it was on your balance sheet at one
million dollars even though if you want
to sell it in the open market today you
would get six or seven hundred thousand
dollars for it
because you said you were going to hold
it to maturity but if your depositors
came and knocked in the door and said we
want our deposits back what you only got
600 000 you got to sell it that is the
manipulation yeah and that's why the
federal facility correct 100 can I ask
you guys a question and this is kind of
to Pat's Point let me just be clear
about the question
you're basically saying the system's
broken we gotta would you say End the
Fed over here Pat's basically like
saying somebody needs to be the bad guy
more almost on a steroid or a heroin
trip right now right now yeah we're
inflating the economy my question is we
know that the administration whether
it's the current uh Democratic
Administration under Biden or whether
it's Trump they don't want to be the bad
guy because why they'll not get
reelected after the election cycle so
who needs to be the bad guy to get us
out of this mess is if the system is
broken is it the FED is it the secretary
who is it going to be I think it goes
back to Pat's Point uh that usually the
way these things end is just slowly and
gradually uh the politicians try to kind
of Dodge responsibility and the people
that end up holding the bag or the poor
and middle class and that's what's very
because if you go through what Pat is
saying okay they come out with more
fiscal that kicks the can down the road
but that doesn't mean that it fixes the
economy every economy continues to get
worse because as an example if you go
back to to purchasing power right we
have had nominal wages go up but if you
look at the actual real wages since 2019
they've gone down so when you adjust for
inflation yeah they're getting destroyed
that's right so we're eliminating Middle
America even though you get these stimi
checks let's say they do Ubi next yeah
right to try to fix the problem well yes
I agree with you the poor middle class
are going to say yeah let's take that
let's take that let's take that I think
but unfortunately it's going to make
them uh worse off over the long run
because they're always the ones gonna
have to pay them but if you're making 40
50 Grand a year and someone wants to
send you money you're never going to say
no we have the same conversation with
Andrew Yang but you know you know what's
crazy let me tell you yeah so so so
let's talk as capitalist here okay who
have have one somewhat won the business
game we're doing okay for ourselves
right okay there's a community that'll
say well that's easy for you to say
because you made your money and now you
got all the money and you want them to
go because you want to see the market
crash and all this other stuff because
that's how you're going to make the
money first of all a true free market
capitalist is going to do good in a good
Market a bad Market a terror it doesn't
matter they're going to excel so if you
print more money and you send five
trillion dollars through the economy I'm
gonna make money why because low and
middle income families don't know how to
spend money still comes to us yeah if
you don't give the money and you hold
these politicians accountable we're
going to go through season where all the
fake capitalists are going to be
filtered out and they're going to go out
and work for a true capitalist and then
we're going to have some real people
that are doing it the right way operate
companies and then people are going to
say I want to work there I want to work
there quite frankly all these banks that
are going out of business you buy
long-term 64 63 percent of your assets
are sitting in that and rates are being
called in a JP Morgan sitting on 14
whatever their numbers was 14 15 some of
you guys are playing the risky game and
guess what you shouldn't be in business
there's guys that should be out of
business so for those that fall into
this trap of all the rich people want
the recession to it nobody wants to
recession to it nobody wants the money
to be printed we simply want
accountability accountability gets rid
of fake players in the game there's way
too fake players in this game and nobody
knows who's who you're not gonna get
accountability because I'm going to
explain to you how it works I live in
South Africa in South Africa we used to
have a reasonable economy today we have
10 hours that have no electricity okay
you have to understand we have 10 hours
a day every single day where the
government switches off our electricity
on a schedule so you get 10 hours of no
electricity for everyone across the
country across the country 10 hours a
day you don't know whether you're a rich
poor middle income they just shut down
they say Fort Lauderdale bang they shut
down Fort Lauderdale has gone from two
to six are you listening now you think
that you think okay you think that's
cool like okay so the studio doesn't
have lots so you don't have lats the
traffic lights don't work which means
that the traffic becomes you can't go to
a meeting because there's no traffic
lights the stores can't operate so now
you're asking for accountability let me
tell you how this happens there's no
accountability it just gets worse and
worse and worse and worse and worse for
the middle and lower class until
something breaks yeah when something
breaks how does the government respond
more money just makes it rain what
happens to the more money
close to the top we have a period like
covert where everyone has more money
yeah the the the the the people that
don't know how to save the ones that
aren't capitalists are unsuccessful
spend all their money and the cream
Rises higher to the top and the people
that are successful rise to that top so
all that all that happens is there's no
accountability and what happens is the
rich get richer and the poor get poorer
I've seen the extreme you guys are
living in the U.S you're not in the
extreme I'm in South Africa I see it the
rich are 0.1 percent the poor are 99 and
the Gap is huge and I'm seeing the state
do exactly the same thing we're on track
the rich are getting richer the poorer
getting poorer the only thing is you
still have 24 hours of electricity just
for now for now some states let's carry
on yeah sometimes in California you
can't use water from time sometimes
we've seen examples yeah you need to be
outside of something you guys live it
but sometimes you need to be outside
let's go to the next story we've been on
the story for a while I'm gonna go to
the next server with Jamie dimon said
and we'll comment on it as well so Jamie
Diamond warns USD that default is
potentially catastrophic asks JP Morgan
has a war room uh he warned the US that
default would be potentially
catastrophic for the economy emphasizing
the urgency for Congress to raise the
debt ceiling and avoid defaulting on
financial obligations Diamond expects
panic in the markets if lawmakers fail
to address the issue leading to
volatility and potential problems in
both the stock and treasury markets he
stressed the need for politicians to
negotiate a deal and come to an
agreement he is preparing for the risk
of a default by holding regular War Room
meetings which will increase in
frequency as the deadline approaches the
standoff between Republicans and
Democrats over the debt ceiling debt
limit continues the Republic with
Republicans seeking spending cuts and
Democrats insisting on a clean debt
ceiling Bill Tom thoughts on this well
you know we've been watching this for
several years now and it really seems
like the potentially cap traffic debt
ceiling is like the latest Avengers
movie we're going to have a whole lot of
stress and a whole lot of things coming
on and then some of it's going to save
us one day at Spider-Man the next day
it's Ant-Man Maybe This Time It's time
for Aquaman but at the last minute a
deal gets cut and Jamie dimon is try he
has seen the stalemate now going on
between Kevin McCarthy and Joe Biden and
you notice that there were three
different meetings that they had over
the course of five days and then it was
all leaked out before McCarthy was in
his limo the White House was leaking out
oh McCarthy started yelling they used
the word yelling
um you mean Yellen no I mean holler
no Janet wasn't there you know it was
just they were hollering at each other
and they the White House leaked that out
to make him look bad before he even had
a chance to get to the microphone and I
know you both follow this what I'm
talking about and I think what's about
to happen is who's going to save it this
time and what Jamie Diamond is trying to
do is push forward to get them to come
together and to agree for the who has
leverage who has more leverage right now
the question becomes who has more
leverage who who truly is gonna wait
till last second who's got bigger balls
and who is more worried about this
hurting their re-election you know any
of that stuff those are real questions
we got to answer I think I think right
now McCarthy has cards he knows it
because it's a bigger election for the
Dems because they could lose the White
House that they have so right now I
think McCarthy has the ability to go
that five percent further and get them
to Blink on his terms but make no
mistake the debt ceilings going up it's
just going to be what other concessions
are underneath that that that deal
that's what I think what we're watching
there is a marketing campaign for a game
of chicken that's what it is you've had
the two marketing campaigners that have
come out in the last couple of weeks
Janet Yellen has come out and panicked
everybody about what's going to happen
if the debt ceiling does isn't it
doesn't get raised she's been on every
single TV station and the next Pawn in
the marketing campaign is Jamie Diamond
But ultimately I think everyone knows
American non-american knows it they're
not going to default on their debt the
US isn't going to default and they did
it's a negotiating tact ticket it's a
negotiating Play Between the Dems and
the Republicans and I think I'm in the
same camp as you I think McCarthy's got
five percent more and that's it that's
that's where it ends the U.S ain't gonna
default yeah I don't follow the politics
too much but from a macro standpoint uh
I don't usually say this but I actually
agree with Jamie dimon I think he's
understating it uh if they default on
those t-bills you you got Mad Max let me
put it to you this way I had my two hour
uh quarterly meeting with my Goldman
Sachs guy before this meeting they flew
in we had the dinner lunch at the house
and we talked about it and their
position was to move money at a certain
bonds because they're not fully sure for
now on what's going to happen between
May June maybe July we revisit unlike
Goldman's taking that position yeah why
is Goldman taking that position you
never know in the history of the last
hundred years only six countries have
defaulted
and we've never default like Russia
Argentina Germany what is it Lebanon
Greece Venezuela it's really those six
have defaulted okay you guys are
thinking we may be one no we're not
saying we are we just think we have to
be ready okay so then you hear you know
the the numbers comes out on how much we
have in our treasury general account
right our GDP right now is 23 and a half
trillion dollars but we only have 200
billion in that account that's like
somebody making 239 a year 239 000 a
year and you got 200 bucks in savings
that's America today okay that's current
America's financial situation 200
billion sounds like a lot of money we
don't have a lot of money but for me
this is what it's going to come down to
I don't remember when the whole midterms
was going back and forth and they
thought it was going to be a red wave
and McCarthy thought he wasn't going to
need anybody from the mega campus like I
don't give a what those guys saying
we can do whatever we want to do to them
and they're like oh that's how you talk
to us behind closed doors no problem
it's not a red wave so just so you need
to negotiate with you need to negotiate
with the guy you hate the most what's
his name Matt Gates I'm right here let's
negotiate you got to call Trump last
minute here call him he's got on the
phone all this stuff because Trump is a
ball-busting negotiator that's willing
to use the threats like the whole thing
in the CNN Town Hall that he says so you
know when you were president you said
this and then yeah that's when I was
president but what's the difference
between now because I'm not the
President right because he knows how to
use leverage does McCarthy have that
kind of backbone to really negotiate and
get everything he wants I don't know if
he has that kind of backbone quite
frankly based on what you hear from a
lot of different people he's more part
of the you know swamp Camp than some of
these other guys are because you know
they're all negotiating with each other
what ends up happening here you know at
the end of the day of course they're
gonna end up figuring out a way not to
default you heard Trump said let him
default let him go through it that
that's that's the DNA of a negotiator
that's willing to go all the way to say
no problem let's go ahead and do this
because in reality let's just say they
do default okay who loses well president
bison can you imagine because of
Congress because of Congress because of
Congress is the reason why we default
and if it wasn't for Congress
President Biden a hundred years from now
when history books write who defaulted
no one's going to say congress because
ain't no one going to remember McCarthy
unless if he comes the president they're
going to say there was a president they
call him the worst president of all time
second to Jimmy Carter and he beat Jimmy
Carter his name is Joe Biden son a
hundred years ago this guy was the
president that defaulted the concern of
putting the fear on Congress Congress
should not be afraid right now Congress
should sit there and say it's kind of
like the movie Air I don't know if
you've seen a movie air with Michael
Jordan and Ben Affleck is playing the
role and sunny is played by Matt Damon
and Matt Damon sits down in the
boardroom and is having this
conversation when Michael and says
Michael
let's face it no one's going to remember
us everyone's going to remember you
they're gonna remember your story
they're gonna tell movies you they're
gonna do this too they're gonna but no
one's gonna remember us we're not gonna
remember Congress is not going to
remember it President's going to
remember Congress has to know if they
have the leverage if they're able to
negotiate accordingly with that then
they can get a lot of things done
especially with accountability if not
it's going to be another hey we need a
few more trillion dollars oh okay here
we go can we go to the same bar together
yes help me out with my re-election bid
to make it a little bit easier next time
in case Trump wins that's the stuff
that's gonna happen I hope I'm wrong I
hope they stay strong because I think
the leverage today is with Congress it's
just we'll see if McCarthy is a good
negotiator maybe McCarthy needs to in
the next 24 to 40 hours take a break
from everybody and read a book called
Art of the deal that this guy who was a
good business guy back in the days been
you know you said out of the deal what's
his name Donald Trump
you said there were six countries that
have defaulted yeah on their debt right
I think that's Argentina
so this is a little naive of a question
because we've never done it in the
United States walk me through what
happens if we do default on our loan
like I think Tom had a great analogy
where it's almost like a Marvel movie
they come in at the last minute but
let's say there's no one to save you
Superman doesn't differ swoop in and
save Lois Lane what happens in America
it's different when it's the U.S so when
Argentina defaulted or in Greece
defaulted okay it's a small country
third world country defaulting on its
debt but you think about all the
countries holding U.S sovereign debt on
their balance sheets and it becomes a
cataclysmic worldwide event and that's
right now
you know what if the U.S missed the
missed one payment the discussion that
he had with Goldman is is irrelevant
because it means that everything goes to
zero so it's not going to happen you
know you know what it is it's like if
the aliens invade Earth I have a feeling
that Russia and Ukraine will fight the
aliens together you know it's that kind
of like yeah right you're talking about
you're talking about something that's so
big and so macro that if it happens
everybody will fight together to make
sure the Democrats and Republicans will
become best friends in making sure that
it doesn't happen when aliens show up
I'm just saying and George you use that
big you use the Mad Max analogy yeah
because I I think it's even so he's
saying that all of these uh Global
governments have these t-bills as an
example in their balance sheet so first
and foremost you have to differentiate
are you talking about defaulting on
payments like they just have to close
down some parks and stuff or are you
talking about default that these t-bills
are maturing and they literally can't
pay back their T bills because those are
two completely separate questions so
let's just go down that path that for
whatever reason the U.S says okay we're
not paying back our our T bills those
t-bills that you have them returning
sure you can go ahead and pound sand so
not only are they on the balance sheet
of these central banks but more
importantly they're the underpinning of
the global monetary system so let's go
back to 2008. the problem that you had
on the main problem is that the global
monetary system was using two main forms
of collateral mortgage-backed Securities
and t-bills and all of a sudden they
woke up one morning and they saw oh you
know what these mortgage-backed
Securities they're not good as
collateral they're not 100 cents on the
dollar and then you have the whole
monetary system implode which gives us
the GFC now we've got one form of
collateral that would be those T bills
so if you take out that Jenga piece
that's the last one now in in who if
it's one day well that Jenga piece come
I don't know but but you don't want to
play that game and going back to his
point which is very good I think in that
type of situation everyone's going to be
on the same side because they're going
to be getting so many calls they're
going to be getting calls from Jamie
Diamond if you're McCarthy would you
take it to that level
well well I don't know how much he
understands the global monetary system
but he's going to be getting calls from
every single world leader saying you
better do this because you don't
understand what the fire that you're
playing with right now if I was McCarthy
I'd definitely play that card because as
you said he's got less to lose because
the reputation the reputation is invited
No One's Gonna you said it you said it
too in in the you know presidents uh
presidents because they want to do good
and they want to be remembered as being
president to do good and no president
wants to go down as the worst president
in history right and I don't think that
that I think the Democrats have just got
I think Biden's got much more to lose
and I think to your point McCarthy's got
five percent more and that could be the
risk that the bond market is pricing in
if I have if I have six bullets in a
battle and you got five I've got more
shots than you yeah but if I can Bluff
you to scare the crap out of you there's
no blast the cards all in the table oh
no no so so so here's here's what's in
the game they're in
in the world of politics
dude the way they use ways to put the
fear of death in you is very different
than capitalism in capitalism someone's
going to say I'm going to recruit away
your best talent and I'm going to take
your best customers and I want to open
up an office right across the street
from you we got to compete right in
politics
you want to do that do you want us to
release that story about you 17 years
ago do you want mainstream media come
and talk about Gina who's Gina you don't
remember Gina on College second year
yeah
Kevin oh you forgot about Gina no
problem hey keep doing that buddy
tomorrow everyone's going to know about
this girl named Gina by the way there's
no such thing as a girl with Kevin
McCarthy and Gina just make I don't want
people
and then you're listening up okay so I
don't know we'll see what happened there
the reality is if it does you're talking
about our currency is going to be
devalued you're talking about global
catastrophic events with economy it's
going to be catastrophic at the highest
level if we maybe move to the next
Global Reserve currency real quick it's
I think maybe an interesting question
would be okay let's just assume that the
they do fix the problem of the debt
ceiling if they extend it then what
happens because to Pat's earlier point
the TGA right now only has I think it's
even less than 200 billion yeah but
Janet has come out and said that she
would like to see five or six hundred
billion in there so let's assume that
they get this thing resolved and Janet
Young goes straight up to the market and
says here's 500 billion dollars worth of
treasuries increase liquidity so then
what does that do you know what does
that do to interest rates if there's not
enough buyers out there for those
treasuries does she scale that in does
she issue all of the debt at the front
end of the curve where there is a lot
more demand and then that you then you
bring down the average maturity of that
32 trillion dollars in debt to you know
from two years down to like one year
then they're much more than the
short-term interest rates impacts their
budget the treasury the federal
government much much more than it did
before that you can literally see them
painting themselves into a corner in
real time let me ask you let me ask you
another question if if in the unlikely
event that there is a default what
assets would you be wanting to hold on
the day of the default bullets
I agree I agree I agree because I've
seen this I agree bullets is a great one
I see this Zimbabwe is just it's one of
our neighbors I've watched the currency
go from something to zero in a matter of
weeks
you want to earn bullets you want to own
property because a house and a property
always has value you want to hold gold
and then to me you would probably want
to hold digital gold that I'm not
pushing the crypto narrative but
if there is a default then there's not
going to be a default the chances zero
comma zero zero zero zero zero one
you've got to start thinking what are
the assets that you actually want to be
holding that's what you're saying
there's still a chance though that's
what you're saying there's always a
chance
I'll play devil's advocate here and I'd
say that you want to hold dollars as
well
uh dollars yeah
absolutely yeah yeah people will be
dumping their tables okay fine so you're
looking at the asset side of the balance
sheet look at the liability side
so all those let's say there's a hundred
trillion dollars in the world right now
which is probably uh okay so you got
acid but how did that 100 trillion come
into existence through debt
so you still got to pay back that
hundred trillion if you want to dump
those someone else is picking them up
you've still got the exact same amount
of future demand for those dollars you
see it's just like you Adam let's say
you've got a million dollar mortgage
right now it's denominated in dollars
and you say you know what Pat I really
don't like what's going on with the
dollar I want you to go ahead and pay me
in Bitcoin or pay me in gold or Russian
rubles or the new brics currency that's
fine but at the end of the month you
still got to come up with dollars to pay
your mortgage you see and what happens
is if the world economy collapses so do
banks there's no liquidity and there's
no dollars in order to pay back all of
those loans that are due at the end of
the month and you have a rush to Dollars
and you see it Spike from 101 on the dxy
up to 120 130 140. it's almost like a
short squeeze on the dollar and that
could be just as disruptive as the as
the um uh the default on the debt and
then Tom brought up a good point it we
kind of skipped over a little bit but if
the the US dollar is no longer the world
reserved currency what's next like we're
seeing what happened with with brick or
bricks to not to preclude South Africa
from that what would happen don't open
that kind of voice because we've been
talking about this D dollarization
theory on our channel for months now and
it is true that
the world is becoming de-dolarized yes
kind of there's more trade happening in
non-dollar denominated uh currencies so
you're getting oil deals done in renambi
or Chinese Chinese or stuff like that
and there's one or whatever Russian
Ruble or whatever you want to call it
But ultimately that Chinese one is still
picked to the US dollar now
is the dollarization happening it's a
process that will take many many many
many many many years but what is the
alternative so okay cool we decided we
all decided we don't want to be part of
the US dollar where are you going to go
you're gonna go to China you think China
is a better option in the United States
look maybe the USA isn't perfect but let
me tell you China is not much of a
better option I don't think you want to
be in the South African currency it
hasn't got a great track record you
certainly don't want to be in the
Turkish lira
so where where you you want to be in the
Russian currency
so the problem is that the the dollar
right now is the best of a bad bunch
but and in order for de-dollarization to
happen what you need is you need for
there to be a better option because
otherwise as capitalists people will
hold on to their money and say even
though this is bad
that option over there is a little bit
worse it's still government counterparty
risk yeah now look we've taken the
orange pool so for us we see Bitcoin and
we look at Bitcoin and say look you need
to have a certain percentage of a
portfolio in a neutral money that's not
linked to any country that's linked to
an algorithm and a mathematical formula
but other than that and again I put the
question to you guys and say
if there is the dollarization and you
guys are forced to do dollarize where
are you going to put your money yeah but
but and the answer is you're going to
rather be US Dollars yeah when you go
back and I I agree by the way and I
think that we are definitely in the
process of de-dollarization that's
that's without questioning the dollar is
absolutely losing its Reserve currency
status but that doesn't happen overnight
it doesn't happen over years that
happens over decades and if you go back
to the last World Reserve currency the
British pound that started losing its
dominance in the 1920s when they came in
in 1944 in Bretton Woods that just kind
of the icing on the cake right and so
what you see is you never have a global
Reserve currency that is implemented by
decree that you have a king or a Putin
or whatever come in and say from now on
we are using this brics new currency
what happens it's always Bottoms Up
so those entities within that economic
system say hey we want to do more
business with the United States going
back to the 1920s right because the U.S
is growing and growing and growing we
have more business we have more
customers there so we want to hold more
more dollars on our balance sheet and as
the US economy grows as a percentage of
global GDP so does the use of the dollar
and that's how it happens so the bricks
or Chinese Juan or whatever yes over the
long run it will overtake the dollar but
it'll only do so as that that economy
overtakes the United States economy as
far as a percentage of global GDP so I
saw a chart of uh GDP of the G7 versus
GDP of bricks and if you look at the GDP
of the G7 it's a chart that goes like
this and if you look at the GDP of
bricks it's a chart that's going like
this yeah so well the trend is there but
still as a percentage it's still heavily
favors the Jews so I don't know if
you've got if you've got that chart it
was a tweet by Gabor gerbeck gerbeck's I
think is his name
um and he shows the chart that does that
and that and it I mean the trend you can
see of when you look at it in isolation
it's nothing but if you look at it in in
in
um over a long period it's actually
quite a scary chart because bricks is
going up and and the and the G7 is going
down and the two crossed a long time ago
kind of kind of like that I also saw
some stats that showed the GDP of China
relative to the GDP of the US forecast
for 10 years from now unlimited it's
scary because the rate of acceleration
in China versus the decline in it versus
the US is it's it's a very there we go
so that's the that's the line that I was
talking about the red line is the brics
countries the blue line is the G7
and that's GDP and that's going from
1995 to 22 to 2025 now the lines of
crust
okay you were talking about people
wanting to hold the currency of the
economy that was growing in GDP trying
that on my glasses there's your number
there's your chart there's your chart
you've got the brics countries growing
in GDP you've got the G7 going down the
biggest economy in the G7 is is the US
yeah so the only other equation is that
uh dollars nominated debt which is
future demand for dollars and how
rapidly you know are looking at another
chart of global uh debt denominated in
dollars outside the United States as you
start to see that decline from let's say
70 down to 65 you're seeing the dollar
lose Reserve status in real time but but
what the mistake people make here is
they when they look at this uh equation
and probabilities is they only focus on
dollars being on the asset side of the
balance sheet and they forget that
dollar liability is on that other side
and that creates future demand for those
dollars and if the banking system
contracts if we have a global slowdown
in economic depression those dollars are
going to be harder to come by now people
say that oh my gosh the fed's going to
print money and the feds and we're going
to do all this money printing that's
fine but how do those dollars get
outside the United States you see the
way they get outside the United States
is the trade deficit well that's fine
that's 1.2 trillion per year but you're
looking at a global economy that needs a
hundred trillion dollars or that has a
hundred trillion dollars in it you know
so that's just a drop in the bucket so
um it's go ahead just try and look for
um I'm just trying to think there's
there's another chart we could actually
show you what percentage of countries
are holding US dollars as part of the
global Reserve or something like that
and what you'll see is that over time it
has declined yeah but that's central
banks so central banks yeah yeah I agree
but I think you really got to look at
the private sector there and then to do
that that's why I like looking at that
uh that debt because it includes the
debt on the balance sheet of the private
sector so I think what we can agree on
is that
dolorization should happen yeah it is
happening the problem is that there's no
viable alternative currency right now
that could displace the dollar so if you
as I say in order for detolarization to
happen you've got to have a viable
alternative you you're basing it on
trade right now there is no brics
currency and if there was one United
brics currency maybe we'd see a
different story yeah and you've got to
have something that interrupts the
network I mean I know you're a crypto
guys you know how important networks are
well that's and and there's there's
never been a more powerful Network than
the dollar okay never ever ever when you
include the euro dollar system and the
global banks that are on dollars so how
do you you penetrate that you know
that's that's I just pulled up the
growth level of bricks versus GDP may be
ahead but size Wise It's not yet
population wise bricks is obviously yeah
that's why I wanted to find it bricks is
yeah size of population it's not even
close but in in in in regards to GDP the
G 7 still has brick speed but growth is
exponential growth is exponential you
can you can by the way the one that is
going to drive it even and they're not
going to slow I don't think it's going
to slow down anytime soon I think India
is going to continue to to do what
they're doing but this conversation
leads to gold in my mind yeah uh here's
an article from Forbes why gold is a
good investment right now may be set for
a new record price gold prices are
approaching at their all-time high with
a 10 increase this year driven by
investors seeking a safe haven asset
amid economic uncertainty UBS predicts
gold could surpass its record price
setting a target of 2200 per ounce by
next march citing factors such as
weakening US dollar banking sector
stress debt ceiling concerns easing
interest rate expectations and the
likelihood of a recession gold's price
surge is primarily influenced by macro
variables rather than supply and demand
fundamentals UBS analysts cleave a
record notes that goals price is driven
by factors like U.S real estate and the
strength of the US dollar the surgeon
gold price is unique as it is unrelated
to its case
so use case what do you think is going
to be happening with gold well uh I
think it's a question of timing right so
if you say is it five years or is it
next five months I'll go ahead and start
by saying that I think everyone should
own gold and I don't really see it as an
investment I just see it as insurance so
regardless of the price I always put it
10 of my portfolio because I don't care
if the price goes up or down it's just
purchasing power it sits that insurance
policy now if you say the next five
months I would say my base case is that
gold actually goes down believe it or
not because I think that's overbought
and if you look at history going back to
covert or the GFC when you have a crisis
situation gold actually goes down
because the only thing on the balance
sheet that these big funds can sell it's
the only thing that has a bid because
it's doing its job right so if you go
back to Lehman Brothers you see that
gold just crashes and then once rates
get down to zero and the market says
okay we we've we've kicked the can down
the road as Pat was saying because we
did all this we'll call it quote unquote
money printing then they gold rips
higher absolutely reps higher and it did
the exact same thing during covid so if
you say the next five months I'd say
there's a my base case is that gold
actually trades lower but if you say
over the next three years or the next
five years I think it goes way way way
way higher but I don't know in real
terms definitely in nominal terms but uh
I again that's what the caveat of I
think anyone should always own gold
pretty much at any price because it's
not an investment it's insurance I think
I agree with you 100 I didn't really
care about the next five months because
that's not an investment Horizon for me
yeah but I think in the long term gold
certainly does continue to go up
um because of exactly what we said we're
de-dollarizing because we've got nothing
to do because we're dedolarizing we've
got nothing else to de-lotterize in
right now there's only one other neutral
Network which is not owned by any of the
players right and that neutral network
is gold right like if you think about
currencies currencies are all linked to
a specific Country Gold is not
necessarily linked to specific country
right it's the second Network now the
law of network effect says that it's
it's called barabasi's law and I can
maybe break down Network effects but
the law of network effects states that
a
in the absence of regulatory
interference users will flock to the
busiest nodes
so what's the busiest note the busiest
node is the US dollar today
so let's just think about what network
effects actually are
if
a network is defined as anything where
each individual user increases the value
of the network exponentially okay so
let's just quickly Define that if we
talk about WhatsApp which is a
telecommunications network if there are
two people on the network myself and
Adam the maximum number of calls I can
make on the network is I can call you
and you can call me two people can make
call this two calls in anything
if we add Patrick to the network I can
call you you can call me I can call
Patrick he can call me and he Patrick
can call you and you can call Patrick
it's another six there's six so we've
increased the value of a network
exponential one person exponentially
so the first thing is that networks
continue to grow at an accelerating rate
exponentially which is the most powerful
effect in the world that's why that's
why networks are so powerful that's why
Google is so powerful and Amazon's so
powerful and Uber's so powerful is
because they are all networks that's the
only thing that they all have in common
that that is amazing now the second rule
of networks is in in the absence of any
regulatory interference users will flock
to the busiest node so I always say if
you're Landing in a new country and
you've got to decide whether you're
going to go on to Whatsapp or some other
chat messenger you're gonna go to
Whatsapp because everybody's using
Whatsapp that's the busiest Network Mode
so it's the same thing with with money
because money is the ultimate Network
the US dollar is the network with the
most users and therefore people will
flock that Network
the second biggest Network
is gold
and so you have to hold you have to hold
gold because of the network effect that
it has in in the mandatory system and
that's why I agree with you I don't have
10 because I think each individual based
on their risk tolerance might be exactly
different but you have to hold gold as
part of your portfolio not to me I see
an extension of gold which is digital
gold and to me that's Bitcoin and so I
take some of that allocation and I put
that's on that allocation into Bitcoin
yeah I was in Turkey a couple months ago
and uh I wanted to spend we all know
that they've gone through this
hyperinflation so I spent a few days
there I had a tour guide this gal was
probably 30 years old and I was
obviously asking yes
but uh my wife should only find out I
have a tour guide here in Miami
yeah all right please don't please don't
tell her it's an end yeah so this
weekend I was in South Beach hanging out
a couple tour guides uh down there
anyway go ahead George but I I was very
inquisitive with pretty much everyone I
met you know I said how are you guys
dealing with this inflation and they're
actually dealing with it very well but
here was this was their strategy what
they do is they get paid in Lira at the
end of the week they pay all their bills
and anything they have left over they
immediately turn it into dollars or gold
yeah exactly what he was saying then I
went through the airport that brand new
airport that was gorgeous and on my way
out I just happened to get a coffee you
know and they opened the cash register I
just happened to look in that cash
register in turkey and all they had in
there were US Dollars well let me tell
you what happens when when you can't get
US dollars because the the flood happens
first of all they use US dollars but
then the problem is that everybody buys
up all the US Dollars and there's not
enough US Dollars and then you know what
they do that's the short squeeze I'm
talking well no they start using airtime
data and minutes in South Africa for
example because we're in Zimbabwe where
you can't get dollars what you trade in
is you trade in minutes of air time so
call minutes or gigs of data they do
that in Ecuador as well but I want to be
very clear for the viewers and I think
you might might Echo these thoughts I'm
saying that the dollar if we have a big
crisis situation you know does that
flight to safety and the liquidity
issues we talked about the dollar goes
up but I'm talking about going up
against other Fiat currencies I am not
talking about the dollar going up
against goods and services in the United
States and this is a hard concept for
people to understand they have to look
at the dollar as two separate currencies
so inside the United States we can have
10 percent inflation
while the dollar is going up by 10
percent outside of the United States
relative to other Fiat currencies such
as the Europe the Turkish lira Etc and
people really need to understand that
concept that makes sense that's good to
make that distinction okay so next story
let's talk about muscular
musk hires an ex-nbc Universal ad in
Chief Melinda yukarno to be Twitter CEO
and people lose their minds so uh this
is a CNBC story Linda yokarino the
former former Global advertising chief
of Embassy Universal has been hired as a
new CO2 Twitter must come from the
higher in a tweet stating that icaria
would focus on business operations while
he focuses on product design and new
technology her appointment comes after
musk's announced his intention to step
down I see of Twitter she brings
extensive experience and a relationship
in the advertising industry which could
help Twitter regain advertisers who have
withdrawn due to offensive content
issues musk acquired Twitter last year
and implemented changes that led to a
loss of AD Revenue car you knows role
will be crucial in building rebuilding
relationship with advertisers and
improving the platform's reputation her
departure from NBC Universal is
immediate and Mark Marshall will serve
as the interim chairman of the company's
advertising and partnership group is
this a good or bad they didn't even did
they put the fact that she's huge in the
world economic Forum yeah yeah she uh I
don't know but I think that's that's the
right they intentionally
so either one of you guys take it to
take the lead on this one what are your
thoughts I've spent a lot of time
speaking about it like I can I can spend
two hours on this topic I'll tell you
why when I was at Harvard the first
thing they taught us around Elon musk's
in recruiting strategy was when he took
over Tesla when he took over Tesla
hidden star Tesla he took over Tesla
from he was an investor he came over
Tesla and they asked what is the first
higher Elon Musk makes when he moves
into Tesla now the question is when you
move into a new company that's failing
and you're going to rescue it watch the
first hire that you make so question
guys what is the first higher that Elon
Musk makes when he joins Tesla it's just
him who does he who's the first person
he has probably the accountant lawyer a
recruiter HRS HR okay cool he's got the
HR manager what's the next person that
that they hire
stops someone to make cause engineering
of engineering okay where does he get
this head of engineering from now this
is where the this is the Mind shift that
I couldn't understand here where does
Elon Musk imagine that you're going to
set up a car you're going to go and take
on all the car manufacturers in the
world you need someone to help you build
cars where do you hire that someone from
from someone from The Big Three which
one which which I want four Jim four GM
Chrysler Toyota or Nissan Nissan's
actually Nissan
no no no Elon Musk head of engineering
from from Google or something from
software what because you never hire
from the industry that you're in you you
hire from the industry that you think is
going to disrupt the industry that
you're in now this for me he hired
someone from the old God I mean he's
he's out to disrupt media and he's
hiring a CEO from the old quad that's
that's not an Elon Musk hiring strategy
so then I analyze this thing even
further and I thought hold on a second
what is he doing here and I think I
understand what he's doing here
the power of Twitter
is actually the product in the algorithm
like if you think about what Twitter is
Twitter is the product and algorithm and
it's not actually the CEO and I actually
think that Twitter would operate better
if it didn't have a CEO I think if
Twitter just operated by itself without
a CEO Twitter would be a much better
platform and we'll get much better
content with a lack of uh with a lack of
of
um of oversight and and policies right
and so I think what he's done here is
he's gone and hired somebody that is
the exact compliment to him so you think
about like Elon Musk the first thing he
did when he walked in he pissed off all
the advertisers he pissed off every
single one of the advertisers did some
damage there broke it done he did a lot
of damage with the stuff like he walked
in there he walked in there with the
kitchen sink you know as a CEO no matter
who you are you don't want to walk into
a company with this kitchen sink he did
Big damage in the with the kitchen sink
I mean you know people may walk around
smiling and some people may have
tolerated it but that the message was
everyone is fireable so damage with the
advertisers damage with the internal
stuff
so now he needs to hire someone that is
going to fix the mess that he made
so he has
Linda she's great she was head of of
Partnerships and advertising at NBC she
managed 100 billion dollar book or
whatever however big the book was she's
famous for combining all the sales teams
of all the channels which means that
he's going to make it profitable because
he's got a track record doing it
but again what is the power of Twitter
the power of Twitter is taken product
the CEO in a private company called
Twitter it's a private company Elon Musk
owns it the CEO is not she's not the CEO
the CEO is the biggest shareholder I
mean you can be the CEO but you got you
got a big shareholder yeah but I think
the elephant in the room is he might as
well have hired Klaus Schwab not really
because she's actually she's she's she's
a world economic Forum but on a specific
agenda which is um the great reset
agenda no it's work it's a it's a it's
the new worker Jubilee the new work
environment she was also on one of the
councils for Trump I think she was on
sports fitness or something so she's
quite balanced in her views she's an
advertising person he needs an
advertising person she's a brilliant
people's person she managed the team of
2 000 people he's not a brilliant
people's person she's he's hiring the
compliment but again the thing that
baffles me the most is that Elon Musk is
known to hire disruptors and not known
to hire disrupted yeah I don't know my
my view is that the the global Elite
especially the world economic foreign
so you're saying that oh she's great but
she's just from this malthusian cult
in this case don't judge a book by the
cover I think let's give it a chance
because everyone's reading two lines in
her CV and already judging her by that I
think well how do you hire somebody then
how do you hire somebody you don't judge
them by uh their resume Pat I think this
is a great question for you I do but but
hold on Twitter's not Twitter you hide
them by the resume but you also have a
face-to-face discussion and you judge
the intellectual the the intelligence
and their emotional intelligence Twitter
and all of us are judging by five
newspaper headlines and and and buyers
and stuff like that I'm not super
excited about it I was super surprised
by this hire but I'm kind of made a
resolution that I'm not going to judge a
book but but by its cover and again I
said to you I don't think that the CEO
of Twitter is such an important position
I think the more important position is
the product manager and The Tech Guy
which is keeping and the owner of the
company which is 100 shareholder who is
also the only person who can fire the
CEO I think there's two options here
number one she's like a secret
libertarian that was just using the
world economic forum for uh you know for
a network right or she or Elon Musk is
just sick and tired of Twitter he's like
I get I gotta get back over to Tesla and
even though she's part of the world
economic forum and even though I'm
coming out and saying that I'm a a
leader in free speech I know that she's
got all the connections and she's going
to keep us from going bankrupt so I'm
just gonna hold my nose and hire her
anyway so I think this is a great
question you know since you have so much
experience as an entrepreneur uh would
you hire someone you know if they came
in and you said hey this world economic
Forum I don't know about that and they
said well look at him I'm a secret
libertarian I was on Trump's board for
the physical education look at the
people that I follow on Twitter they're
all you know Ron Paul and whatnot would
you give her a pass or would you be
suspicious enough to say I just I just
don't trust this gal what do you think
so so first of all Elon Musk always
reminds how broke I am you know when
when
I talked about this this week in Dallas
and it's great because there's always a
guy that you can compete with in the
marketplace but I don't know the whole
story I'm gonna give it to you from the
outside perspective from my POV so why
did he buy Twitter I actually answered a
question on why he bought Twitter
Twitter wasn't the best investment for
you to buy you could have bought
hundreds of companies better than
Twitter in regards to investment you
know like you know if you were to sit
there and say he could have bought a
complimentary company to Tesla to bring
them in and do XYZ he could have bought
so many different companies so why do
you buy Twitter you bought Twitter
because he was concerned of freedom of
speech with all the stuff that was going
on it was a cause-driven thing that he
was doing okay no problem then after he
bought Twitter we didn't yet know
because he originally bought 9.2 percent
whatever the Morgan Stanley announcement
you know Elon is now 9.2 but he doesn't
want to be on the board he just kind of
wants to be on the outside and oh it's
going to be all right next thing you
know he wants to buy the whole thing but
he's not going to be firing the CEO now
it's not really going to be happening
you know Professor Galloway comes up
watch He's not going to close all he's
trying to do is manipulate the stock and
he's trying to hurt them no he ends up
closing anyone said I don't think it's
gonna really he's not going to daily
operate no he was responding back to
everybody customer service he can get a
hold of oh my God Elon just retweeted me
oh my God just responded to me oh my God
just like my tweet everybody's like damn
this guy's how the hell is he doing this
does he sleep at night he's at the home
office he's still this is so the whole
thing was cause driven and then the
messaging was for us to get away from
relying on advertisers then you go hire
somebody whose strength is in
advertising you're confusing the
audience on why you bought the company
in the first place so to me the biggest
confusion is why'd you buy Twitter if
you bought it because you wanted to be
that person
then this may not be the best person to
hire so ask the question why well she
recognized Larry Fink from BlackRock
what a great job he's doing and we need
to pay attention to ESG and I don't
really know if there's anything really
fake news fake news is really from the
people that are the non-journalists the
true Journal journalists from the
mainstream media they don't have any
kind of fake news seriously that's
against his philosophy of what he's
doing so the the messaging while we sat
there we just had an editing Chief and
he's saying so you know what is success
for me here as a success for you here is
for us to not need sponsors and
advertisers right now we have three
major gold companies that are bidding to
be the main gold sponsor for uh uh for
the brand and we're doing hardcore
investigation on who these guys are and
they're putting some real numbers behind
it we're not talking like a multiple six
we're talking about a real sponsor but
guess what here's how we don't do it
okay this is who we are this is how
we're going to sell it you can't get to
tell us what not to talk about all this
other these are bylaws on what we do
right why I don't want to rely on a
person telling me what to do I'm in a
negotiation right now of a time you know
the story of a a sports team okay that
that uh I'm working on potentially
anyways so we've gone back and forth
okay this has been going on for how long
now 12 months 11 months I think it's the
one year anniversary of the kickoff of
those negotiations every background
check you can think about has been done
on me and again just to be a
professional
minority owner of a well-known
sports team that we're talking about
right one of the four major sports that
we're talking about
you know where it's at right now here's
where it's at right now
why this could happen and it doesn't
happen it's listen we see where you're
at with your positions we don't like our
owners to say stuff like this
and we don't and then I have to go have
a meeting with them right now literally
I'm having a meeting with them next week
okay because they watch your content and
guess what my meeting is going to be
about what I'm going to say I'm telling
you I needed an email that if I become
an owner you're not going to tell me
what to say and what not to say because
I left Iran so I don't have to fear
freedom of speech and I can tell you and
I made money so I don't have to be
controlled what I have to say and what I
don't have to say when I was running an
insurance company I was getting on stage
talking about certain things people were
saying you can't be saying stuff like
that go to another company
you can't be talking about that kind of
I totally get it so so for me my concern
here is you and selling this philosophy
of not relying on advertisers and then
you hire this person you know how weird
that is it's kind of like this it's like
saying you know hey we're gonna go and
be a the one the way we're going to win
a Super Bowl championship is by the
Pittsburgh Steelers model let's have a
strong defense Baltimore Ravens strong
defense NFL draft becomes first six
rounds each person you pick is all an
offensive player wide receiver running
back quarterback running back fullback
wait a minute you missed after that
linebacker that guy's a linebacker
defensive human what are we doing here
so it's like I think that's the biggest
thing in the audience do you think he
just got in over his head like initially
that was his game plan but then when he
actually looked at the revenue company
is like if I keep doing this I'm doing
bust and nothing jeopardize Tesla so
okay that was all fine and dandy but now
the rubbers met the road and I gotta
hire someone that's going to keep us
afloat before you before you answer this
let's just consider two things go for it
he's got debt holders people have debt
he he didn't put the money in himself
the dead holders are maybe looking at
this and going look Elon you can't be
treating the advertisers like this
ultimately you've got to repay our debt
watch your monetization model then 2024
is a very interesting year right what
happens in 2024 election and Olympics
okay two of the biggest advertising
events in the world
two of the biggest advertising events in
the world but let me get this straight
so do you realize what do you realize
what they said the other day with uh did
you see the Richard Dreyfus interview
when they said what it takes to win an
Oscar nowadays did you hear about what
it takes to be nominated for Academy
Award City what you have to do as a
company did you guys read this article
or no and you heard what Richard driver
said okay can you pull this article I
just want to read this to people for for
them to realize go go to news go to news
and the article will pop up it's New
York Post or Washington Times pick
either one of them uh uh uh anyways I
have it right here so I'm guessing this
has a high Dei ESG for you in order for
you to be considered
in order for you to be considered for
Academy Awards now okay you have to have
a certain number of actors in the movie
that are uh uh uh part of the lgbtq
community you need to meet I'll read the
article to you so Hollywood new
diversity Hollywood no diversity uh let
me just close this up a Hollywood new
diversity rules are making one actor
sick legendary actor Richard drivers
condemning the inclusivity changes that
will be implemented for next year's
Oscar saying the new standards make me
vomit this is an art form it's also a
form of Commerce and it makes money but
it's an art he says this in an interview
with PBS firing line with Margaret
Hoover and no one should be telling me
as an artist that I have to give it to
the latest most current idea of morality
is Richard Dreyfuss goes off and says
what we are risking what are we risking
here are we really risking hurting
people's feelings you can't legislate
that and you have to let life be life
and I'm sorry I don't think that there
is a minority or a majority in the
country that has to be catered like that
and it goes into breaking down what
they're looking like on screen
representation needs to be a certain
percentage and you know it's classified
at least one lead character from an
underprecedented racial or ethnic group
having at least 30 percent of secondary
roles be from an uh two under percent of
groups or mainstream do you see how much
of an you know story this is
where they're going with this right so
the the categories each pertaining to
different aspects of movie production
would require new diversity measures to
be met on-screen representation creative
leadership project team industry access
opportunities audience advancement okay
so now go to Olympics what do you think
is going to happen with Olympics now
no but that's what but that's why I
think he's hired someone that's the
opposite of him someone who knows who's
head of Partnerships but she's head of
Partnerships but she's gonna come in and
she's gonna say the Olympics said
they're gonna give us 50 million dollars
if we're able to recognize transgender
as such and such or if we can Shadow ban
uh Patrick that David yeah
I don't think we're saying the same
thing I'm saying in the Olympics Nike
are going to want to advertise Adidas
are going to want to advertise all the
sports brands those are ESG companies
yeah but they're all going to want to
add those are all ESG companies buddy
this is a ward this is not a regular
thing we're talking about here to to
take a stand I'm not a rumble guy I'm we
do our stuff on a YouTube yeah but I
love what rumble's doing I think Rumble
is necessary I'm not a Spotify guy we
put our stuff on Spotify but we're not
like going out there saying all right
let me buy Spotify stock Spotify is
necessary when they protected Rogan what
he did with with uh Twitter he scared
the crap out of everybody in Silicon
Valley he took a company Twitter and
then from there there was talks maybe he
buys CNN people started shivering they
could no longer play games Tucker goes
to Twitter now you want to go out there
and start giving somebody like this
that's going to go to advertise and say
hey we could get 100 million dollars
from these guys but here's what we need
to do we need to make sure we do this
and we need to
I think he's the one that's going to
protect the we're not budging
Etc she's the one that that is good at
partnership she goes to Nike and says
look we can't really do that but you
know what we can do everything at the
end of the day ends with two words we'll
see okay no everything is going to be
we'll see okay we'll see but to me you
didn't have to go get somebody from
World economic Forum you could have
gotten somebody from a lot of different
places
have been part of that if like you know
I could be part of the world economic
forum and do it for completely different
reasons right and I'm still keep my
principles and my libertarian views I
could be doing it just to get inside you
know you keep your friends closer in
your or your your enemy your friends
closing your enemies closer do you think
that she could be kind of a a
Libertarian at heart or a free speech
Enthusiast well no have the same
worldview but was just in that for her
job maybe you don't I'm playing Devil's
advocacy please keep playing Devil's
Advocate I want you to keep playing let
me say my thoughts on this unresponding
cure okay yes you could hire your
president that somebody's from there
your CEO no problem CTO fine CMO cool
CEO no
because CEO has to buy into your
philosophy and the vision
I don't think you can do it with your
CEO again guys like I said it musk
always reminds me how broke I am because
the guys made a lot of money I'm a big
fan of what he's done we talk about him
in a very uh respectful way in a place
like this but I don't think you can get
a CEO that doesn't fully that goes out
there and says fake news doesn't exist
and thinks Larry Fink and BlackRock is
doing a great job with ESG and thinking
ESG and Dei all this stuff are great
things that are being done no you you're
you're you're going to cause concern in
certain people that got there and stared
you know started being active on Twitter
because they finally realized I'm not
going to get and after Twitter files one
two three four five how many times did
we realize who's being this and who's
being that so now guess who's going to
be doing the hiring who's going to be
hiring the people in the company alone
no she is who's she going to hire who's
she going to bring in okay so so who now
if I'm the CEO I run a company I run
multiple companies now so who who's do I
get approval on who to hire no I'm
hiring the person I don't go to the
chairman the board this is who we're
going to bring as CMO yeah and you fast
forward two years and Twitter is Twitter
that's the point yeah so hold on you're
not you're not considering two things
first of all it's a private company
with a with a majority if not 100 of the
shares held by by one individual in a
private company you have a CEO but the
real bus is the owner it's not a public
company where there's there's a boy it's
Elon Elon whatever Elon says eventually
goes she knows that the second thing is
he is Extreme on the one side
when you extreme on the one side you
piss a lot of people off internally and
externally what's the best strategy to
mitigate that bring in the Yang bring in
the Yang and lit if it's only about
money if it's only about money ran yeah
if it's only about money and you were
doing this to make money and figure out
a way to increase your 45 billion
dollars you should have looked elsewhere
you could have made money in different
places
go in this direction and compromising
the real threat that we have with ESG Di
Dei all of these things that's going on
in media people are sitting there
looking at candidates that are criminals
yet the real criminals are the one that
are being sold as Angels it's kind of a
weird time we're living it so this guy
who did this now again I've hired people
and from the outside people are bitched
about who I hired and they say I can't
believe you hired that person how could
you pick her and how could you pick him
and why'd you make her to CEO you think
she can be the president you don't know
what you're doing totally get it I get
that but but my concern if it was money
you should have bought a different
company if it was a cause you really
wanted to be that cause guy then stick
to the cause and hire somebody that's a
CO that's more be more a registered
independent coming from a different
space who's the real who's the real CEO
of a private company in a technology
sector just quickly is it is it the
owner plus the CTO plus the project
manager or is it the appointed CEO
ask the question again who is the real
CEO of a private company that relies on
this technology is it the owner plus who
is also the CTO and the product manager
or is it the appointed CEO who's the
real CEO I know what you're saying but
also on the flip side George Soros just
sold all his shares with Tesla Public
Announcement I don't know if you guys
saw this or not he's leaving you know
Tesla and Tesla is not in the best shape
right now with all the criticism they're
getting and Tesla was at 1.8 trillion
dollar company so you're talking about a
company that is calling left and right
for Elon to go there and do this this is
not a guy that's you know just doing
Twitter by himself and he's going out
there hanging out this guy's this guy's
got a lot of stuff on his plate so I do
think when you bring somebody like this
who is coming in you know her
personality is like here's what the
personality is like I guarantee you in
an interview she asked the question of
Elon I'm fully convinced she has this
question Elon you're going to let me run
the company or am I going to be one of
your employees one of your friends that
you do everything through them or you're
going to let me run this company so I'm
not leaving NBC Universal if you're not
going to let me run the company
zero to a hundred what's the chance that
she asked that question in the interview
100 okay perfect so guess what he's
gonna she's gonna say so what can we put
in place for me to know you're gonna let
me run the company
there has to be an agreement okay so if
he starts trying to impose she doesn't
like it we're going to hear about it
within three to six months and who's the
world going to side with
you know there are a lot of different
people that I'm sure he interviewed a
lot of different people that he could
have gone through
um there are a few things that are
philosophically against what he believes
in and she doesn't think it's a big deal
isn't that philosophically isn't one of
the philosophies in a company like this
that if you really want to make it um uh
neutral then you've got to have someone
very strong pulling left and someone
very strong pulling right no I don't
think so I think there's one thing you
don't have to be neutral in I have no
desire like there's one thing we do when
we hire people here you know what it is
here's I'm not neutral about this you're
gonna read a book every month and write
a paper on it
seriously I'm not neutral about it I had
a person in the company that says well
Patrick this is you remember this this
is too much you know people are stressed
that I said nope that person needs to
leave they don't read the book of the
month I agree so what you know what we
did we created in our bylaws day one
when we're hiring pre-hiring agreed to
read a book every month to write a paper
on it you're serious I haven't read
about totally get it if you're not going
to do this isn't a company for you okay
two here's what we believe in in
valuetainment what's that I don't care
if you're any ethnicity any sex but I
care that you know that capitalism is
the way to go we don't sit here and say
well we should have a couple Communists
here as well and let's have a communist
CEO run it and let's see how valentayman
does it's okay let's have a neutral
because I'm so much of a capitalist a
swing of communist no you cannot
compromise freedom of speech but you're
talking about a capitalistic company
with capitalistic ideals this is a
different business this is supposed to
be a neutral platform which is not about
being monetized yeah but neutral by
definition is freedom of speech so if
you've got someone's wearing the left
and we're on the right I totally agree
with you have to agree on free stuff
again I I'm skeptical of it I've agreed
not to judge a book by its cover I'm
just making the counter case here yeah
having studied a lot of elon's hiring
decisions in the past this one was one
that truly surprised me and this is how
I've rationalized it over the last
couple of days uh since it came out what
did you say I wouldn't have heard about
when he hired her did you actually see
his tweet no what'd he say he basically
said that she's gonna be running
business operations he's going to be
running product Designing Technology and
together they're going to turn it into X
the everything app we talk about this
all the time whether just more than us
free uh Free Speech platform they want
to be the the go-to everything app like
what do they have in China what's the
go-to app that they have there uh
exactly that's essentially what he wants
to do let's play a little game yeah
um how long is she gonna last let's
maybe all just write down on a piece of
paper how long is it gonna last and then
let's meet again and see how many
basically your argument is ends justify
means but then that goes back to what
Pat was saying it's it's what's your
priority here because initially your
priority was freedom of speech and now
all of a sudden your priority is profit
and growing the world's biggest app so
where are we here Elon you know what
what's your true objective what happened
Elon passed that the one there was one
Sunday where Elon tweeted Sonny and he
said if you post any links on your
Twitter which take people out of Twitter
that account was going to be banned it
was to that one platform
but it wasn't any subject the way it was
what it is the word was what it is if
you post any links to go outside of
Twitter what what happens who is going
to push back on Elon when he does
like that because for one weekend I shot
myself because I use my my Twitter to
promote my YouTube
and I post links to my YouTube show as
you guys post to your podcast and I sat
then I thought if this goes on my
account's getting banned here because
every second tweet is listen to my
podcast meet me at Patrick with David
sure
someone needs to push back
because otherwise it's the e-launcher
and you're saying that should be her I'm
saying I'm saying if you were gonna hire
someone to push back you want to hire
someone that is push pulling the other
way and not someone that it's not a
business it's a platform that is
designed to a neutral
I I understand fully what you're saying
and I don't disagree that you need
somebody that's going to do uh of you
know certain things for example okay
marrying a wife
what's more likely for the marriage to
be catastrophic ready both are
Christians
one is a communist the other one is a
capitalist or
both are capitalist one's a Christian
one's an atheist what's more likely for
the marriage to work out
what's more let me ask the question one
more time okay they did a study on this
I'm gonna ask the question I want to
actually think about this okay
you got a husband and wife
both Christians they met at a church one
is a full-blown capitalist
she believes you know in personal
responsibility right you can do
something about it the other is a
communist thinks rich people are greedy
they have character flaws they're
selfish they marry each other or husband
and wife Mary they both believe in
capitalism one's a Christian one's an
atheist which one is more likely to work
out so you're asking the level of idea
of of uh importance of what is more
important religion or philosophies of
how to live life I would say I think it
depends on kids assuming there's no kids
in the equation I would say the atheist
and the Christian have a better chance
what do you say Tom I think the atheist
and a Christian have a better chance
because if there's no kids because I
think that would get real complicated I
think I think it's different I think
that you're defined in hierarchies and I
think the higher I think I mean I
haven't thought about it but I think
you're defined as being male and then
being of a certain religion and then
being of a certain philosophy I think
but I haven't thought about it long
enough my parents got married they were
both Christians they both believe in
Jesus they both believed in God okay my
mother was a communist my dad was a
capitalist
I cannot tell you how catastrophic that
was in a household and how confusing it
was I can't even describe it to you huh
what a hot mess it was okay one believed
rich people are greedy and they're
terrible human beings
the other one believed poor people are
lazy and they don't do anything to take
full responsibility for themselves they
divorced twice in 20 years okay my
parents twice in 20 years okay
in in this case
the premise of what you brought
everybody in
was freedom of speech was anti-esg was
anti-dei
I don't care about all the other stuff
that was the core values and principles
I I don't care about all the other
things that you do but the values and
principles has to be the same I don't
care what religion she is I don't care
what religion he is I Don't Care What
ethnicity
philosophically they're not on the same
page One Believes fake news is only by
others that are content creators and he
believes fake news can happen from
mainstream media because he exposed
everybody with the Twitter files one
believes that you know Larry Fink and
you know all these guys BlackRock and
ESG they're doing a good job for society
because we need to really contribute
back and so the other guy's like not for
it and now all of a sudden you
one's most likely an authoritarian a a
collectivist and the other is an
individualist so you know how does that
one pan out as well so listen again the
the great thing about this show is we we
debate topics and then we find that 36
12 months later who's right who's wrong
and we're so comfortable with that
nobody hears you know shooting for 100
free throw ratio as long as we're
shooting 80 plus we're okay with that if
this is the 20 that I miss I'm very
comfortable because I think elon's an
absolute son of a guy so I think that
they get divorced I think these two get
divorced
what's your over under
I don't know because
it's there's to what standpoint as a
tourist guide or he's going to fire her
Justin Trudeau I think I think um I
think she lost
6 to 18 months so I don't think she
makes the over 18 months and I think
that Elon will tolerate her for the
first six but I might be wrong all right
let's go to the next story here CNN I
want to kind of talk about what's going
on here with CNN CNN boss quick lick
facing Fury of criticism within the
company over Trump's Town Hall we
haven't yet responded to the story
because we've been gone for about a week
so we have to kind of touch this story
here what happens so he's facing
criticism after the company brought in
former president Donald Trump a platform
to spread lies keep in mind spread lies
and his conspiracy theories during a
town hall the decision was widely spread
criticized with one staffer stating I
can't believe anyone thought this was a
good idea CNN's own media owner all of
the Oliver Darcy reported on the
backlash following the town hall
describing CNN and Chris Licht as facing
a fury of criticism the network which
has been trying to move away from its
left-leaning coverage was accused of put
accused of putting moderator Caitlyn
Collins in a no-win situation despite
the criticism chrislich defended a town
hall in Collins performer stating that
the obtained Trump's answers and made
significant news he dismissed
suggestions that Collins did not push
back hard enough on Trump's claims and
emphasized that the job is to get
answers and hold the powerful
accountable Licht also praised Collins
stating that she exemplified what it
means to be a world-class journalist
and as tough Fair revealing questions
Tom uh did Chris Lake do a good job did
he make the right decision having Trump
on and what are your thoughts about all
these people losing their minds well I
don't like everything that's in
chrislich's personal belief structure
and platform but he was brought into CNN
to somehow bring it back to a more
balanced credibility with the viewer
that was his mandate we have to remember
what was the Mandate Chris we're off the
edge here we got to come back at least a
little bit you may be on a one to ten or
a nine but you gotta get us back to like
a seven and you gotta have something
that
um gets us in a position where we can
win some viewers back and he got rid of
Don Don Lemon and there's a bunch of
things that happen so I think what
happened here is that he's trying to do
that and he was honestly and by the way
you know once upon a time there was an
advertising comment that was made about
CNN and he says man are you in our
Revenue every quarter sucks since they
canceled that cool Desert Storm show and
um this goes back no this goes back to
the war this comes back to the Wolf
Blitzer and the war and remember that
CNN made Bank on Operation Desert Storm
let's face it because they had something
something to do right now they don't
have anything to do all that what do
they have to do maybe Trump maybe
DeSantis and hide for the president so
what has happened here is Chris Licht
has done what he was told but it is so
endemic what's inside there that the the
natives I have just come to his office
calling for his head and that's what
happened how could you because they see
themselves the media sees themselves as
a liberal Defender they see themselves
as the defender of that they are
basically like a political activists
yeah they're defense lawyers for the
president when his son's in trouble
think about that they're running to the
microphone putting the spin on the
defense strategy for the presidents
rather than covering what is happening
to the president so Chris slick that
we're supposed to do and it blew up
because there's a lot of people still
there that are as you say political
activists that haven't moved yet moving
a network under a mandate is really
really hard it's those damn people and I
think CNN is just a year ahead of fox I
think Fox is going to be in the same
position I think this is smartest thing
that CNN's done in a long long long long
long time let me explain to you why I
think it's the smartest thing to do in a
long time because when you're dealing in
media and you're dealing with viewers
the problem is that when you do damage
to the viewers the damage the viewers is
cumulative so if you start off with a
media channel you've got 100 people
watching you and you have set five of
those hundred people and they leave
you've got 95 people watching you and
then you do damage again you lose
another five years you've now got 90
people watching you and so your Market
gets smaller and smaller because
inevitably in media you're going to
upset people that's how it works
I think the only way to bring the 10
people that you've lost back and and
more is to do crazy that you
ordinarily wouldn't do
and I think that that's what they did
here this is this is something that CNN
wouldn't ordinarily do I think this is
something that brought a whole lot of
viewers to CNN and I'm gonna be honest I
haven't watched CNN in years since since
Desert Storm the Desert Storm series I
haven't watched the CNN in years
but now I just remembered who CNN I just
remembered there was a channel called
CNN and I think it was I think they were
the big winners here I think they were
the big winners in the night and I think
that we need more of the traditional
media companies that are falling to do
extreme things like this which they
ordinarily wouldn't do to try and bring
back the cumulative viewers that they've
lost yeah I think the conjective is
ratings it's a it's a win but if you're
uh if your main priority is being
objective I think it was a loss because
this is not Twitter no this is not
Twitter this is not Twitter is maybe
objective these guys are off the money
and sponsorship manual sponsorship comes
after viewers and CNN's dying if you're
dying you do extreme things yeah yeah I
get it well all of mainstream media is
done Legacy media's dining so that's my
point if you're looking at I think 95 of
all cable shows uh not not are all as
far as most watch shows are on Fox
so if you're seeing that if you're
Quizlet and you're looking at Fox
Dominate and then all of a sudden they
let go or whatever happens with Tucker
Carlson and you're like all right our
number one competitor is now drowning
half Their audience is basically what
what's the average age of a fox dealer
65 and it might even be older than that
you're desperate you need to do
something and what's the most desperate
move you can do is bring on Donald Trump
you haven't had on your air in five
years almost we're just hired Dylan
Mulaney oh yeah
but this is it but now all of a sudden
ran nor all of a sudden is basically
watching CNN again when you haven't
watched there in years and how many more
Americans or International audience are
doing the same thing I haven't seen this
tweet I haven't seen this tweet but I
agree with it at the first line CNN I
think there were two real winners that
night CNN and Trump
that was the big and those are the two
big winners for me on on the night of
that debate both of them shocked me
both of them shocked me CNN shocked me
because of what they did and how they
owned what they did at the time like at
the time they owned it another one that
shocked me was Trump you know you know
who is you know why they're so scared so
think about why you're ski you're never
scared when somebody performing performs
shitty you're like oh that was great the
guy was an idiot he looked like a fool
he was like the only reason you're angry
is because he crushed it right only
reason the audience I can't believe the
audience was clapping form how dare they
clap how dare they clap for the guy you
know those are that's exactly they got
3.3 million viewers okay uh most watched
cable news uh network of the night 780
000 people in the critical 25 to 45
advertising demo employees are
complaining and bitching you're in a
media space you're supposed to get
eyeballs that's what your job is that's
like Dana White not making a Conor
McGregor fight because Conor will
promote proper 12 and all he'll do is
increase the value evaluation of this
drink who gives a let him do it
anyways this is another reason why Dei
and ESG scores cause CEOs of Fortune 500
companies to make dumb decisions to
please a crowd I think lick did a great
job now if they fired a guy uh we're
hiring in the CEO right now
if they fired a guy if they fired a guy
and he's sitting there saying are you
freaking kidding me that's the job he's
trying to do and you want to do
something like this to him this is an
opportunity for CNN to sit there and
right after Fox got a black eye if facts
a fox got crushed by what they did to
Tucker Sienna is now winning and
Dominion this is a phenomenal
opportunity for CNN they should be
celebrating but Anderson Cooper said I I
understand some of you may never want to
watch this network ever again and I
understand why but shouldn't we see the
other side shouldn't we give people the
opportunity to expose themselves like he
just did shouldn't we do this just just
leave it that is why Food For Thought do
you think it could be a Bud Light moment
this is why seeing this is why CNN is on
the theme
of course it says okay we're protesting
we're never watching you again you're
right it could be it very very well
could be a Bud Light moment where you
know what the problem is you just said
you've just mentioned the whole problem
there's there's momentum inside an
organization and someone went against
the momentum of the organization the
problem is
the question is whether the jolt was
enough to disrupt the momentum of the
organization and Insider because if not
it's like it's like a meteor coming from
the earth yeah and the the direction is
done because everyone's pushing down and
what he did was he tried to push them
back up and the problem is that Anderson
Cooper apologizing and and it's just
everybody pushing the the the the the
meteor down back to hit the ground you
know what's the biggest difference
between this and uh Bud Light Bud Light
try to cater to a point zero one percent
of population
transgender drink and Bud Light I don't
know if I've ever seen you know like
that just doesn't make any sense I'm
trans and I drink Bud Light yeah it
doesn't make any sense CNN try to
you know Mark it to 50 of America which
is not a bad strategy to see if they can
get those viewers this job of what Chris
lick did salute good job for you what
but light did that was it let me just
reaffirm exactly what you're saying so
if you're if you take mainstream media
as an example if you look at every
single show late night show on ABC NBC
CBS you go Colbert you go Fallon you go
Kimmel they're getting these are
professional all-time comedians they're
getting freaking crushed by who
Greg Gutfeld who has a read off a script
to tell a joke why because he has 50 of
America just tuning into late night Fox
whereas they're just cannibalizing each
other so essentially CNN just took a a a
page out of the book of fox and just
saying all right let's just cater to the
largest market share whereas the let
these guys just eat each other and Greg
Gutfeld it's not funny is Colbert Kimmel
any of these guys fouling but he's
beating them so I mean just look at that
nothing what happens to his ratings once
Tucker's gone to see if like you know
the tide raises all boats
I think let's transition into Bud Light
guys we've had enough Elon Musk honestly
let's give all right guys bring in some
beers but light parent company stock
downgraded by HSBC emit Brandon crisis
huge sales drop this is the Fox Business
story HSBC downgraded Anheuser brush and
Bev stock to hold the citing a crisis
following Bud light's marketing campaign
with uh transgender activist Dylan
mulvani HSBC Carlos Laboy expressed
concerns about the Brand's response the
and the significant drop in sales
stating that the way this Bud Light
crisis came about raises many questions
sales are butt line in the U.S plummeted
reaching one percent of the company's
Global volume in the uh in sales uh
stating uh uh one way in the first three
weeks of April retail sales store sales
of Bud Light also experience a sharp
decline of 21.4 compared to the previous
year in contrast Coors Light and Miller
Lite saw sales increase by almost 21
percent exactly the same
same percentage the boy questioned the
decision making and risk assessment of
Abi's leadership that's Anheuser-Busch
asking why did this U.S leadership
underestimate the risk of pushback given
the recent experience of other firms is
a b hiring the best people to grow the
brands uh grow the brands engage risk
that's the question so do you think
America how we are we forgive we move on
they're going to do a bad wise or
they're going to do a commercial the
frogs are going to make a comeback and
we're going to be like you know what man
that's just I'm reminiscing yeah I want
to have a bad life forget this guy they
fired her do you think we're forgiven or
do you think this is going to be
something that's going to be around for
a while let's surprise McKenzie I Gotta
Throw That one in there going Way Way
Back that's a great question I've tried
to think about this and I think over the
next year it's going to be a big deal
uh I I think over the long run as far as
the overall parent company I don't know
if it'll make that big of a difference
because they have so many other brands
so many people don't even realize you
know people think that if they're you
know go from Bud Light over to XYZ it
might not be coordinate something else
that they're doing damage but they don't
realize they're just going from one of
their products to another of their
products I I don't know that it'll have
long-term consequences but uh I could be
wrong I hope I'm wrong yeah I think if
you look at it as an individual brand or
if you're looking at a company you
figure it as an individual brand yeah
this is what what matters now is what
the competitors do with the opportunity
because now that now there's weakness
now there's there's something for the
taking and it all depends on how the
competitors responds and I don't think
the response is in a week or a month I
think as you said the response is what
happens in in the next year but I think
Patrick's right I think Americans are
very forgiving
so they're forgiving until you break and
I I don't think that I don't think
that's broken I think people tend to
forget I mean I think Pat's absolutely
right they're one good commercial away
and about six to 12 months away people
being like ah you know what those Bud
Light guys we're drinking again yeah but
at the same time like the the the there
was two commercials that Dylan Mulvaney
did that people that pissed people off
number one was the March Madness
commercial where basically
he she it thee them whatever he is
couldn't Define what March Madness was
he's like I think it's something about
it was just so obnoxious and the second
one that pissed people off was the one
in the bathtub and
and to rand's credit about his
capitalizing Coors Light did a
commercial of a dude just kind of
sitting back in his bathtub yeah exactly
how many dudes are just taking baths and
they called it the best seat in the
house and he's watching a game kind of
like a macho man watching a basketball
game you know in his bath uh versus
juxtaposed that with
her oh doing her little dance in the
bathtub but Bud Light has been some of
the made some of the greatest
commercials of all time between the
what's up yeah he changed this um
well we know who approved it it was that
one lady basically saying listen for
forever Bud Light was this sort of
fratty bro type of brand and we tried to
move away from that but it's like that's
your Market
dudes who drink beer yeah not
she females that that drink I could
argue beer and bathtubs I could argue
the other side too because you know uh
if if I have it if I'm going out let's
say like as an example when you came
down to Medellin I think I was drinking
old Fashions and I yes I love old
Fashions drink over the last five years
or but now I was turned on I don't even
know how to uh
Don Julio Don Julio 70 and man that is
good and and now I drink that when I go
out and the old Fashions are just part
of History so maybe maybe people that go
from Bud Light to Coors Light will never
ever go back and they have to rely on
the the younger people that are coming
into drinking age going to Bud Light and
that will definitely take some time but
it'll be very interesting to see how
this plays out Adam's more of a rose guy
he likes desserts
hey if you're buying I'm drinking that's
the kind of guy these are these are just
bad American beers but for Branding I
American America is forgiving but I
think that this one's gonna fling for a
little bit because the longer this trans
thing and what's going on the election
is there I think that doesn't help them
on their effort to bounce back but
there's so much Heritage and so much
brand Equity as it's called with
Budweiser as a whole I think there's an
opportunity for them to come back but I
do not think that this dialogue and all
this controversy on trans is going to
help it go away anytime soon because you
have to remember you need the
controversy to go away and the longer
the controversy is gone the longer you
know remember once upon a time every you
know the female football fan in America
was upset with Brett Favre because he
was sending images and stuff and
everybody was disappointed in me wasn't
our hero anymore but the longer it was
since that and his wife had breast
cancer and he had a divorce on her there
is a real Schism that was there but
guess what if
people have get on with that longer the
controversy is away from you and the
more you just show who you are after
saying you wouldn't exchange a text with
Brett Favre today like you're over it no
I
don't know
I want crazy images
Charles Barkley who was talking to Ernie
about it and he said I just got one
thing to say Brett if you're gonna do
that the one rule is is got to be
ginormous can Charles Barkley said that
it is like shaking his head you know so
I I think the longer I think the trans
controversy is kind of Charles you know
kind of normalize a little bit Yeah and
then that will be away from the brand
and the brand can make a comeback
that's a bonehead move how would you
feel right now going to a parable going
to a party and holding a bad life yes
sir this is what I was gonna say well
I mean right now today you're at a party
you're at a pub you're at a nightclub
and somebody hands you a free bad light
now is it in a can or is it I mean
[Music]
fist fights when they're drinking cans
yeah this is this is this is the serious
thing this is a very good point
Tom when you were drinking Bud Light in
a can at the bar the other day tell us
what happened hang on I'll give you a
real world example yesterday take my
daughter we go
down see Miami Marlins you know
and we got standard Stadium food and I
noticed that right there it was just
like the pictures you see on social
media that I was thinking maybe they're
making it up they took the picture of
the you know the the Bud Light counter
nobody's standing there maybe they took
that when it just opened and nobody was
there it was legit nobody was standing
there they were over there getting
Yingling and other beers that were there
but that little Bud Light stand that
poor person is sitting there the little
blue shirt come on and they weren't
buying ran hit a nail on the head no
dude wants to be at a stadium in a Bud
Light line while he's trying to get
something else
how many guys were Adidas who was Adidas
you wear Adidas yes okay you know Addie
Adidas ADI Adolf Founder's name was adol
yeah and you know what Adidas is linked
to what you're not seriously if you're
gonna tell Nazism I didn't know that's
what it's like I thought it was two
brothers one of them was well it's
linked to that when you go to the dark
history of Adidas right and if same goes
with Volkswagen as a young man yeah but
the point is I mean if you were Adidas
today and if you were Volkswagen today
Demi's eventually going to drink Bud
Light okay the history tells us and
that's what I'm asking how long but how
long is you know could be you know he
said one year I don't know I don't know
one to five years and and by the way the
way you do it is the following here's
what you have to do it here's what you
have to do you have to fire the CEO
immediately because you have to show
everything Rises and falls on leadership
this happened under his watch I agree
you fired a CEO you fired a CMO you
fired a marketing department you find a
replacement immediately then you make a
statement saying we have to go to a
different direction and here's what
we're doing we brought XYZ from this
place his background's got to be
military his background because you know
the currency used to be a CIA agency you
got to bring a different kind of a guide
that comes in and maybe you're going to
say hey I got this guy he's more boom
here's the New Vision this is where
we're going to be going and I'm on the
rest of history people move on so this
happened but for now they're going to
take a hit you know when you look at the
stock market curve and you look at the
hardware up up and then you see covert
yeah and then you see it goes up again
this is covered this is uh bad lights
Black Swan but if you zoom out in 100
years you'll eventually just go what
you're saying is if in a week
you get an email okay them asking you a
question saying hey we would like to
sponsor your podcast would you take it a
hundred thousand dollars per month I'm
not a chance about a hundred thousand
per month not for sale a million in
episodes not for sale we will let you be
the CMO to Linda the new CEO of Twitter
would you take it not for sale so you're
not going to take anything from Bud
Light right now no but you will a year
from now
and you were Adidas why don't you do it
okay I would need to see what I would
need to see what they did lifetime
supply of Adidas shoes with Bud Light
and a brand spanking Volkswagen parked
outside zero to six in ten seconds I'm
just I'm just thinking about
I'm thinking of a practical I'm thinking
of a practical question can you imagine
a guy can you imagine any guy walking up
to any bartender in any club can you
imagine how he would order the bad light
now it's like
just Whispering out there well I won't
whisper this I'll make a public
announcement at the CEO of Bud Light if
you want to pay me double what you paid
Dylan Mulvaney I'll jump in a bathtub
right now
let's go and also value 10 minutes
looking for Value time is also looking
for a headline sponsor and uh they are
in talks with three you said there is
first base for a fourth no because Gold
light it's not a high-end you know there
might be if this was Hennessy maybe
there's people that would defend
Hennessy that's a high-end beverage but
Bud Light is not a high in beverage to
make Bud Light if you feed a gallon of
water to a horse and put a bucket under
the horse right that's how you make butt
life it's a simple filtering process
let's wrap it up we got a couple guys
here that know a thing or two about uh
crypto
I want to wrap up with the story on
blockchain and get both your thoughts on
it so it's two stories one
uh federal reserves fed now will connect
with medical with metal blockchain okay
with metal blockchain and the other
story is going to be about what golden
Microsoft are doing with blockchain so
first one fed now
the federal reserve's upcoming instant
payment service fed now will be
integrated with metal blockchain
allowing metal users to convert funds to
stablecoin and vice versa using the FED
now system send and receive function fed
now is set to launch in July and will
enable round-the-clock near instant
payments between Banks metal blockchain
developed by metalicious metal licus
offers compliance friendly options for
decentralized finance D5 developers and
emphasizes bank secure bank secrecy act
compliance Etc et cetera and it was and
I'll give you the other story as well
the other story is Goldman Microsoft
sibo and others team up to launch
blockchain's Network this is a Bloomberg
story group of firms including Goldman
Sachs Microsoft Deloitte sibo Global
markets is teaming up to launch the
Canton Network a blockchain system aimed
at linking institutional applications
and promoting wider adoption of
distributed ledger to technology and
financial markets the network offers
improved privacy and controls along with
scalability and standard suitable for
financial institutions what are your
thoughts on these two stories
how do you think the Market's going to
respond to this I think both of these
stories are on nothing burgers and I'll
tell you why I'll go through it so metal
with all respect to them known the
company or the protocols since since
they launched back in the day they
launched an apparently Richard Branson
was one of the investors and they've
been looking for an identity since and I
think that this announcement would
impress me a lot more If the Fed came
after the FED said hey we're not we have
picked this blockchain provider so
that's my response to the first story I
think it's a nothing book I think
regarding the Second Story
by definition blockchains are open
public Ledges otherwise they're just
glorified databases and they need to be
permissionless and not controlled by
anyone and and that is why Bitcoin has
been so successful and that's why
ethereum is the second most successful
because it's permissionless it's not
owned by anyone it's not controlled by
anyone it's not it's not um swayable by
anyone when you're talking about these
companies
these are exactly the companies that
blockchain is trying to move away from
them being controlled and so you know
you can make as many announcements as
you want but ultimately let's look at
who's going to be using your blockchain
and what they're going to be using your
blockchain for right now the most used
blockchain between I mean you had two
two blockchains which are really both
being used which are Bitcoin and
ethereum and the one thing that makes
them both that used is the fact that
none of these corporations are are able
to control it structure it fund it
Finance it they can use it as equal
players as if we use it and that's the
beauty of these things so I think it's
like this is both of these stories for
me on aren't really big stories I think
we'll hear about it here and I don't
think we'll ever hear about these
stories again to be honest yeah I mean I
don't follow the the crypto stuff the
Bitcoin stuff uh as much but I just look
at this from the standpoint of the
Central Bank digital currency which I
think is what most people are really
worried about right that's scary when
they read about fed now and fed now is
basically centralizing uh the settlement
process and the Clearinghouse that right
now is done by a quasi-free market
process so whenever you have
centralization or something like that I
don't like it but I also want to
highlight something that he was saying
and using the word Ledger
because people need to realize that that
money or let's say currency outside of
green pieces of paper really doesn't
exist
all it is is a ledger system that says
hey the Bank owes you this much and so
it's like time you you really can't all
you can do is keep track of it right so
my point here is when people hear fed
now they get really freaked out about
Central Bank digital currency but they
shouldn't I want to make sure that
people who value privacy Freedom Liberty
and free market capitalism focus more so
on The Ledger and less on the currency
as far as the Central Bank digital
currency because if and I think that
we're going into this tough time like we
talked about earlier and I think one of
the solutions that they're going to
provide so the depositors don't take a
haircut is to move your deposits to the
federal reserve's Ledger right and when
you move all of these deposits to The
fed's Ledger now you have that ledger
centralized including the back end
Plumbing which is fed now and that by
definition gives you a central bank
digital currency regardless of what they
call call it so right now when I see
Florida
Banning Central Bank digital currencies
or I see Ted Cruz in Texas doing the
same thing I think that's great that
it's bringing attention but I'm very
concerned that the globally leader using
this as a diversionary tactic because
they're they're starting this Central
Bank digital currency fire over here
while at the same time they're creating
an environment where you could
centralize that ledger and and people
are so focused on that Central Bank
digital currency they wake up in six
months and like how on Earth do I have a
social score because they don't realize
that the the fundamentals of a cbdc is
moving all those deposits onto one
Ledger more centralization and that's
the first thing that I think about when
I see this article off the covet the
scariest thing in the world for me is a
central bank digital currency because I
don't think people understand the
implications of what a central bank
digital currency does and I think for
those people who are hearing about this
for for the first time or not that okay
with what it actually means
right now if you've got dollars in your
hand you can spend those dollars how you
wish because there's always going to be
a buyer or a taker to take those dollars
out of your hand but when there's a
central bank digital currency the
government can literally because it's
all digital they can control where you
spend and what you spend and they can
catch you off at one point if they own
the central the central Hub of electric
on one Ledger if it's on one Ledger if
it's on one Ledger and that is what
they're gearing up for they're gearing
up for Central Bank digital currency now
just I mean let's just quickly compare
Central Bank digital currency with what
happened with covert so during covert
they were they were um we had to stay at
home and there were curfews and you had
to be at home past a certain time and
you couldn't go in the morning now one
way to enforce that is to just say hey
guys you can't leave and if you do leave
you better be part of the uh um
essential workers oh I was going to say
Gavin Newsom is a private part another
way to do it another way to do it is to
just cut off your spending and basically
said you listen you cannot spend money
between 10 a.m and 10 pm cannot spend
money wherever you go you will not be
able to touch money under your bank
account
that is a very very scarce now let me
give you just a practical example say
you have a baby and your baby needs
diapers and you have a little emergency
you go to the store you want to get
yourself a set of diapers you walk into
the store you grab the diapers you try
and pay for the diapers sorry the the
government said that you can't spend
money between X and Y let's take it one
step further government doesn't want you
to eat red meat anymore just doesn't
want you to eat too much red meat you
want to go and pay for your steak they
say sorry you've had you've had eight
steaks this month
that is the power that we give
governments if we get a central bank I
would also add issuing credit based on
narrative instead of Merit so as an
example you know if you take everything
out of the one balance sheet the FED
can't go bust
so they can issue loans they don't need
to be paid back they could care less so
you don't need to give them a credit
score
so what happens is Adam goes down to the
local bank you know you got to talk to
Jerome Powell to get your next mortgage
and they say hey you know what we heard
what you said the other day yeah Pat
yeah that ain't gonna happen your social
score is a negative 10 or whatever but
Dylan Mulvaney
goes to Wells Fargo and the throwing
money at him and he's got a 500 credit
score why because he is part of that
group that is part of that political
narrative you see that that woke
narrative and and that's why having that
all those deposits on the same Ledger is
so crucial for them to implement these
orwellian policies that all of us should
be extremely concerned with but the
focus needs to be not so much on the
cbdc but all of those deposits going
onto one Ledger that's what people have
to push back against and the good news
here is that it's currently illegal if
you go to the fed's website they say
that it is illegal for them to hold
accounts of individuals so we all need
to be cognizant of that so if they try
to change that law or if they try to
circumvent that law that we can hold
them accountable and that's what this
half is all about who would lead the
charge in the United States for that to
actually be implemented well Jerome
Powell is the one that's been speaking
about it so Jerome part is the one that
has mentioned that they were looking
into a digital Central Bank digital
currency by the way if you think that
this is very far away it's not like in
China it's happening in China they've
they they they have been dealing with
Central Bank digital currencies for for
many many years and there is a festival
I think it might even be Chinese New
Year where the idea is that you give a
red envelope and inside the Red Envelope
is a gift and the gift is a certain you
know whatever it is and they actually
did a campaign in China where they had a
red envelope campaign but with a cbdc so
that people actually adopt a cbdc to see
how much money that how much money
they've got and that's an adoption tool
once people get used to using the
Central Bank digital currency you've
given the government the ultimate power
have they already implemented a social
credit score in China is that actually
social credit scores in China but
remember it's not the the Central Bank
digital currency is not yet Mass adopted
there is a list I don't have the website
but there's some website that actually
shows a list of all countries and how
close or how far they are from being
able to to implement a digital currency
a central bank digital currency what's
the top of the list I think China and I
think there's like African countries
there like I think Nigeria I I can check
the tweet in a second but for me the the
scariest thing is if we get a central
bank digital currency you have got to
make sure that as much of your money on
the day that that Central Bank digital
currency is a reality you've got to get
as much of your money into a neutral
system as possible
unfortunately I think you're going to
have a problem there as well that people
really need to be cognizant first of all
you know they you never let a good
crisis go to waste so if we have a
banking crisis the FDIC comes in they
got 200 billion okay great there's 18
trillion in deposits so an easy solution
is drone power riding in on the White
Horse and saying hey move your deposits
from Bank of America over to the fed and
you'll never risk taking a haircut done
deal right that's what the Average Joe's
going to say going to uh the point that
he was making which is very very good is
it it's it's people need to realize you
can't program money because it doesn't
exist just like you can't program time
okay so in order for them to get the
data they need to know whether Pat
ordered a tow food burger at the
restaurant or he ordered a steak because
that's going to go against his climate
scores carbon footprint score for the
month right they have to have that
detailed data right so I've been talking
Robert Barnes the famous lawyer about
this quite a bit and he thinks that
they're going to have the IRS come in
and to get your EIN number you're going
to have to use their point of sale
software and so whether you pay with
Bitcoin or whatever they still could
attach that purchase to your uh the
algorithm that would still crank out
that score you know I took some of my
employees from Columbia to Disney World
because that's on their bucket list
right this weekend when I was in Orlando
and I don't even know if you know this I
was shocked I went in there I bought the
ticket and you know in the old days you
just buy the ticket you give it to the
guy he'd kind of rip it and then you'd
go through the little spindle or
whatever right now what they do is you
you buy the ticket it's got a QR code on
it you go up to the spindle you have to
stop right there they take a picture of
you you then you take your QR code you
scan it then you give them your
fingerprint
you see now whether they're doing this
intentionally or not the bottom line is
they're conditioning people to give
their fingerprint wherever they go right
and so the central planners I think are
going to take advantage of this and say
Hey listen this point of sale software
that you're using in order for me to
take your order at Chipotle just go
ahead and give me your fingerprint and
you can pay with Bitcoin silver gold
dollars I don't care but then once it
goes to your fingerprint it goes to the
IRS it goes on I don't mind that I I I
don't think that I mind that I don't
think that the world should be about tax
evasion and to be honest like you don't
know tax evasion know what they're doing
is they're doing that in order to get
the detailed information as far as what
you're buying because right now if you
go to Chipotle your Wells Fargo
statement shows you spent 20 bucks but
it doesn't show exactly what you bought
I don't even mind to be honest if they
collect that information about me like
that you don't care if the central
planners and the authoritarians have
that information on every single
American I don't care as long as I
control my spend but if you take that
and you take away my ability to control
my spend that's where the pit like for
me I don't mind record whether I eat too
many nachos or tacos or who the hell
cares as long as you don't control my
spend as long as I have the the right to
do whatever I want with my money but if
you take that and you combine it with
with ownership of my money and telling
me where I can spend and next time I
walk into Chipotle and I want to buy
something it says sorry we have deemed
for some reason that you can't buy this
that's the part that worries me yeah but
that's how they get that's how they
collect the data to determine whether or
not you can buy that in the first place
and you you sound like somebody that
would want as a spokesperson because you
know for us when we're not concerned
about things like that everything starts
off with being sold as it's not a big
deal what's the big deal you know what's
the big deal you know it's not a big
deal we're not trying to do anything and
then all of a sudden it's like well I'm
already doing it anyway so next and next
next some people would even say George
just started with your phone you pick up
your phone and sees your eyes iPhone
boom absolutely you know and then you're
you're in it and so look at the end of
the day cbdc is something that a lot of
people are concerned with and it doesn't
matter whether they're crypto or not
crypto they're concerned about it and uh
I think if there's ever been a time for
us to stay more paranoid as a collective
today's the time to stay more paranoid
than ever before enjoy your life but
stay paranoid because there are some
people that have different motives than
uh I don't think then we do but I don't
think the average person understands the
implications of a cbdc I think to them
it's just I think that when the cbdc
comes they're gonna disguise it as a
gift but they won't call it a cbdc
because it's got too much negative press
you want just you're just going to call
it moving it on to the fifth balance
sheet that guy that's so paranoid about
the cbdc is going to say great move my
account to the FED balance sheet I don't
care but as long as you don't do a cbdc
and he's going to wake up six months
later and he's gonna have a social
credit score you want just you you want
your stimulus check no problem let's
take the balance in your bank account
we'll top it up with two thousand five
hundred dollars but you have to now move
on to this new this new spending system
and close your account to JPM thank you
very much and to be clear it could be JP
Morgan's balance sheet it just has to be
one it doesn't necessarily you do you
don't want here's something interesting
just to prove that point about The
Ledger I went back and did a video the
other day on the bank of Russia it was
called gauze bank and it was there from
1922 to 1991. okay and if you read
everything it did it's just like reading
a top 10 of what the central planners
could do with a central bank digital
currency and I sit there and I ask my
audience and I did this in the
presentation how could they do how could
they manage credit how could they know
every single transaction that you're
doing how could they basically give you
this credit score they didn't even have
computers right why the reason they
could Implement that is because
everything was on one Ledger and that
because it was the only Bank in the
whole country the central bank was every
single Commercial Bank and it couldn't
go bust therefore it could issue that
credit based on narrative basically
everything that you should be concerned
with about a central bank digital
currency and they didn't have a cbdc but
they had one Ledger that's the real
devil in this story that's uh we're at
the end of the podcast this was a great
podcast I think you guys got a friend
here uh funding Jim yeah he's a very
good friend of mine 500 uh uh what do
you call it uh Super Chat uh good friend
for many years on the show looking
forward to
the highest of stakes movie release true
D5 crypto will rise funding Jim Gary
Woods did you want to put a shout out
for the highest uh Stakes movie release
oh Gary's a good friend he's down in
Medellin he's part of my my Mastermind
group uh he's a great guy
the next Pablo Escobar from America
going to Mexico to start a new movement
a Freedom Movement I like it we're going
to try to spread throughout it man keep
doing it you guys are doing a great job
again ran uh and uh George thanks for
coming on we're going to put the link
below to your podcast if you have to
choose one of the two which one would
you rather do Gammon or the rebel
capitalist uh Rebel capitalist okay so
let's put Rebel capitalist at the top as
well as uh crypto banter you guys can
find them it'll be in the chat in
description and in the comment section
this has been a blast I believe we're
doing a podcast again tomorrow yes we
are what time is tomorrow's podcast 9
A.M 9 A.M tomorrow we have Mike Tyson
and Michael Francis in the house at 9am
just drop that right
it's gonna be fun we will see you guys
tomorrow morning gentlemen thank you
again for coming up thanks for having us
safe travels back to South Africa and
Medina thank you everybody bye-bye